Und ich hoffe es ist nicht Corona, aber mir gehts nicht schlecht oder so, ich muss husten.
Tut der Hals ein bisschen weh, aber ich hab kein Fieber und nix.
Aber ich muss husten und das sagt.
Ich hab extra Noisegate, nee nicht Noisegate, so Clipping im Mikrofon drin, das falls ich
euch mal ins Ohr husten muss, dass es da nicht so laut wird.
Ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das erzähle, weil der Stream ist eh noch nicht richtig on.
Jetzt gucken wir uns erstmal Patch Notes an, Patch Notes, Massive Patch Notes, Huge
Patch Notes.
Aber erstmal warten wir, bis Twitch gecheckt hat, dass der Stream online ist.
Hab ich denn überhaupt das richtige Game eingestellt?
Ja, Battlefield 2042, exquisite.
Kamikaze Keiler, danke für den Prime Sub.
Propaganda Beef, moin.
Also Leute, ich warte nochmal kurz, bis Twitch gecheckt hat, dass das richtig on ist.
Was ist denn heute Donnerstag?
Donnerstag?
Ah ja, Donnerstag, cool.
Bis wann kann man noch vor Weihnachten Amazon bestellen?
Bestimmt bis 21.
Oder wahrscheinlich sogar bis 22.
Weißte es jemand?
Amazon 22 bestellen, noch 24 kriegen, geht das?
Wann kann man bestellen?
Das haben die doch sonst hier immer stehen.
Amazon.de, Weihnachten bestell Datum oder sowas, eh, Amazon, so bestellen sie ihre Weihnachtsgeschenke
rechtzeitig.
Das gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, das ist überhaupt nicht das, was ich wissen will.
Das ist überhaupt nicht, diese Bestellfristen, nein, nein, nein, Weihnachten bestellfristen,
ok.
Bestellfristen Amazon, drehe da durch, also ich vermute ja mal bis 21 kann man auf jeden
Fall bestellen, eventuell ja auch mit Express dann bis 22, manchmal sind die ja sogar so
mutig und sagen, du kannst 23 mit Express, aber das würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
drauf mich verlassen, ja.
Übrigens Leute, jetzt wo ihr jetzt wo ihr alle am Start seid, ich muss euch was sagen,
ich habe kein Corona, aber ich habe Husten, ich sitze hier mit dem Schal, habe jetzt schon
Tee gesoffen vorher und äh trinken hier, also ich glaube nicht, dass ich Corona habe,
weil ich habe kein Fieber und nichts, ich habe nur einen trockenen Hals und muss husten
und mir tut der Hals ein bisschen weh, also ich denke mal nicht, dass es Corona ist oder
sagen wir mal so, ich hoffe nicht, dass es Corona ist, aber auf der anderen Seite selbst
wenn es Corona ist, wenn das nicht so schlimm ist, dann ist es ja auch egal, dass es Corona
ist, ihr wisst, was ich meine, Terrorkicks, moin, also wir gucken uns jetzt mal kurz die
Patch Notes an, wo ist die Musik, ein Stückchen, es gibt keine normale Erkältung, es ist ausgerottet
normale Erkältung, es haben sich natürlich insgesamt weniger Leute angesteckt durch
die ganzen Maskenstellungen und sonst was, bei allem was halt nicht so ansteckend ist
wie Corona, aber ich glaube Husten um die Jahreszeit ist durchaus normal, ich glaube
die meisten haben sich schon impfen lassen, also ich habe heute die Statistik gesehen,
an jemandem Radio erzählt, ja ich höre manchmal noch Radio, dass es an sich halt wieder voll
abgeht mit impfen, aber die Erstimpfungen gehen halt nicht hoch, aber das wundert mich nicht
letztendlich, die, die jetzt immer noch gesagt haben, sie lassen sich nicht impfen, die werden
sich auch in Zukunft nicht impfen lassen, also das wundert mich nicht, bei allen anderen
klappt das ja, ich bin ja auch geimpft, ich habe meinen Boostertermin im Februar, an
einem Samstag, mein Hausarzt ist samstags da und macht Boosterstells, er an den anderen
verdient da Geld damit, also der Nächstenliebe, der Nächstenliebe, er macht da das auch nicht,
so wir gucken jetzt mal kurz in die Patchnotes rein, also ich sage es jetzt nochmal, wundern
ihr euch nicht, wenn ich heute ein bisschen huste, ich habe ja auch Schal an und T am
Start und alles, das hat sich jetzt die letzten Zeit ja schon abgezeichnet, heute ist ein
bisschen hustestells, als wir angesagt, Yatsi, oder Yatsqui, je nachdem, wie auch immer,
drei Monate Subscription, huge, massive Subs, und hier Nierdu auch am Start, fünf Monate,
dankeschön Leute, so gucken wir mal kurz Patchnotes, also was haben wir denn hier schönes, was
haben wir hier schönes, Patchnotes, Notepads, ich finde es geil, dass die immer damit anfangen
und keinerlei Referenz dazu im Spiel richtig zu finden ist, außer dass die alle irgendwie
was von Notepads labern und es den Irish Story Trailer gab und sowas, hat das nichts mit
dem Game zu tun, die haben lieber coole Weihnachtsmannskins, gucken ob das jetzt in-game ist, der Weihnachtsmannskin,
also Last Week Update, bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla, alles klar, also, Hit-Rack
wurde konsistenter gemacht, was auch immer das heißt, müssen wir gleich mal gucken,
es wurden angepasst, wie sehr sich die Kugeln verteilen unter Rückstoß, dann wurden wohl
die Waffen auf Fahrzeugen gepatcht, oder wie auch immer, was auch immer sie da angepasst
haben, 30mm, 40mm, oder 57mm, dass die weniger gut gegen Infanterie sind, das ist tatsächlich
nicht schlecht, weil gerade in Hazard Zone, also den Modus, den im Endeffekt keiner spielt,
aber anscheinend doch mal ab und zu mal Leute eine Runde spielen, also ja, ist widersprüchlich,
aber was ich meine ist, keiner spielte länger als 4-5 Runden, aber ab und zu spielen halt
mal Leute ihre ersten 4-5 Runden, da ist es das Meta, ja, dass du mit dem Auto rumfährst
und alles wegflext, ich finde, die müssten die Helis allgemein ein bisschen besser an
Infanterie anpassen, Helis sind einfach mega krass in dem Spiel, das war in Battlefield
3 und Battlefield 4 nicht wirklich viel anders, in Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4 habe ich
halt hauptsächlich auch die Karten gespielt, die nicht viel Heli und Luft und Air Gameplay
hatten, deswegen habe ich beispielsweise Caspian Border und Firestorm gemieden, das konntest
du, es war aushaltbar, wenn du auch ganz gute Piloten hattest, dann haben die sich gegenseitig
beschäftigt, aber wenn du Jet und Helistelzer am Start hattest, die die ganze Runde nichts
anderes gemacht haben, als das, war halt ätzend, außerdem konntest du in Battlefield 3 einfach
in Haus gehen, dann war Ruhe, so, so, das habe ich, also entweder hatten wir das schon
mal, als ich mit der Pepega 29 die Leute da irgendwie 20 Stück am Stück wegrasiert habe,
entweder war ich da unsichtbar oder irgendwas war verbackt, wie funktioniert der Hype-Train
eigentlich, wenn du innerhalb, nee jetzt ist vorbei, da doch, doch, wenn du, also wenn
du innerhalb der, also ich glaube, dass das so funktioniert, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine
Ahnung, als müsste ich mich hier mit Twitch auskennen, ich glaube, das ist alle, die in
dieser Zeit subscriben, haben die Chance, Emotes zu bekommen und danach kann man die Emotes
irgendwie sharen mit den restlichen Leuten, irgendwie so, kein Plassen-Schimmer.
Etwunder, wenn ich mich ab und zu mute, dann muss ich husten und wenn heute ab und zu das
Mikrofon kratzt, dann liegt das daran, dass das gegen meinen Schal kommt, also weiter
gehts.
Bugs, Granatenwerfer und Launchers, Xbox Player, wen interessieren dir die Console Peasants,
Multiple Audio Improvements, ahja, das ist natürlich gut, dass man die Leute jetzt besser
hört, je nachdem wie weit die weg sind und wie nah die dran sind, also ganz ehrlich,
was von Anfang an im Spiel sein soll, Designer-Schal, nö, übrigens, wo wir gerade beim Thema Designers
sind, guckt mal, letztens, habe ich letztens gesehen, äh, guckt euch das mal an, da könnt
ihr mal kecken jetzt, Leute, da könnt ihr keck wehen, Alter, wie ihr einfach die Grimmzange
am Start habt, jetzt ein billiges China-Multimeter, noch eine andere Grimmzange, da muss halt
aufpassen, dass ihr das Zeug dann rausfällt, ne, so, so geht man in wirklich, jetzt ist
der neueste Trend, so geht man zum Technik, so geht man in den Serverraum demnächst, also
eine billige AliExpress, ah, der Endhülsengrimmzange, oh, Omikron, nein, nein, nein, ich klicke
nicht auf Religionsfreiheit, nein, Max, nein, keine Twitter-Trends, Deutsch, ah, ah, zumachen,
das fällt mir schon schwer, ich muss zumachen, ich darf mir Twitter-Trends in Deutschland
nicht angucken, weil ich reg mich immer an, das ist keine Satire, das ist ernst gemein,
ich darf keine Twitter-Trends in Deutschland gucken, wenn ich Twitter-Trends gucke, egal
welche, reg ich mich auf, also, was ist denn jetzt das Detail-Update, ok, das interessiert
mir nicht, ja, das ist für Hazard-Zonen, Audio-Tweaks, Indoor-Door-Steps gefickt, Clarity-Distance-Direction,
wie man das auffasst, das ist gut, da hört man vielleicht Gegner ordentlich, die bouncing
jetzt nicht mehr, die hitten direkt, ok, ich hab das Ding noch nie verwendet, Underbarrel,
Noob-Doop, ja, das ist die One-Hit-Sniper, oder, ok, PP29, wie der entnerft, keine Ahnung,
was er immer das heißt, Hipfire-Accuracy für alle SMGs, das Dinger sind eh jetzt schon
krass, LMG ist noch besser gemacht, ok, Not-Pog, ja, und hier ist die Geschichte, wo angepasst
wird für Anti-Infantry-Vehicle-Gameplay, die müssten aber mal was an den Helis machen,
weil die Helis wrecken, wie Sau, Infanterie weg, LMG ist ja auch grad Metawaffe, ich hoffe,
der Motion-Sensor haben die nicht, haben die nicht, Reduced, Moment, ist da Motion-Sensor,
Sensor, oh ne, warum, da kann ich ja gar keine XP Farben mehr, gibt's jetzt irgendwelche
Kanaten, die überhaupt noch zwei Stück, ähm, haben, Frags, Ding, Smoke, Smoke hat noch zwei,
ja, das wäre auch bescheuert, oh man sieht hier Hazard Zone bekommt nichts, gut Hazard
Zone ist auch dead, deadge, so, Kaleidoskop, die Objectives auf dem Haus sind weg, das
ist schon mal gut, Orbital ist gleiche, Hour-Class das gleiche, das war ja auch mal das Mindeste
um Breakthrough spielen zu können, vielleicht spielen wir sogar noch eine Runde Breakthrough,
aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich das psychisch ertrage, ok, naja, gucken wir uns das ganze
mal an, Bäm, oh guck mal, wer spielt denn hier Battlefield 3, wer spielt denn hier Battlefield
3, der Elschmagovatz, alles klar, start das verdammte Spiel, aber wir müssen jetzt, wir
müssen gleich umstellen, sonst lagts nämlich im Hauptmenü wieder, ich lass mal die Musik
kurz an, weil das Spiel hat ja eh keinen Soundtrack, Charlies waren useless, Charlies werden immer
noch useless sein, dich können 30 Milliarden Drohnen spotten, Motion Sensor spotten, Leute
spotten, Helis spotten, Spotter spotten, Fahrzeuge spotten, was kann er nicht spotten
in diesem Game, wie groß ist der Patch, ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ich hab das hier nebenbei
laden lassen, ohne dass ich geguckt hab, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht, Size, guck mal mal,
Size, nö, keine Ahnung, vielleicht weiß es im Chat jemand, ja mir wärs auch lieber,
man könnte ordentlich flenken, oh, Weekly Missions, ja gut, die müssen ja uns was verkaufen,
ich, ich hab eine Woche Zeit, ein Shotgun, seriously, ein Spiel, was im Prinzip über
riesen Ranges spielt, Hauptsache ein Shotgun, oh Gott, jetzt rennen sie alle, jetzt rennen
sie alle mit Schneiber und Shotguns rum, na da hab ich ja schon Bock drauf, eh, ok, also
Arm, Diffuse, Destroy, Objective, Rush, alles klar, das kriegen wir hin, Revive 50 Teammates
bekommen wir auch hin, 30 Enemys mit Shotguns und Marksman Rifle, come on, na gut, inviten
wir jetzt erstmal PC, wir inviten den Captain Poggers, wir inviten den Fatal, falls sonst
noch einer will von euch, dann sagt Bescheid.
Ihr müsst, wir probieren jetzt mal was aus Leute, ich lass es jetzt mal auf Display Capture
und ihr müsst mir sagen, ob es ruckelt oder nicht, ich mach schon mal meine Vorschau auf
dem Handy an, weil dann seh ich das immer am besten, Handy, Mag Source, Live, gut, lustigerweise
ist bei mir die Vorschau auf dem Handy am besten was das angeht, sehr merkwürdig das aber gut,
ist halt so, ne, alles klar, eh, Memory Leak, ja, da isser, ne, wagt's rum beim Join, kann
das sein, macht's ja manchmal, ah ne, da isser, ok, Captain Poggers nochmal, auf geht's, so,
was, was probieren wir denn jetzt mal aus, was haben wir denn hier schönes zu bieten,
Gun Master of Ages by Jack Frax, ah, da sagt mal einer Jack Frax ist nicht mit Dice im Bett,
Rush, Conquest of Ages, Rush of Ages, die Frage ist, ist Rush of Ages dann mit den jeweiligen
Soldaten aus dem jeweiligen Teil oder mit Battlefield 2042 Specialist, hm, das ist die
Frage, weil die Umsetzung von Battlefield 3 und Bad Company 2 ist kompletter Müll in
Portal, deswegen will ich das eigentlich nicht spielen, wir spielen jetzt ein paar Runden
davon, aber please nicht, nicht Defender, wenn wir Defender sind, geh ich raus, ach,
du hast das nicht mehr, ah ja, gut, ne, dann nicht, hätte ja sein können, ich will dich
bestimmt nicht dazu überreden, das zu kaufen, ganz, ganze hier nicht, also wenn noch einer
will Leute, sag Bescheid, ne, wir haben noch zwei Plätze frei im, im Squad, jawoll, Attacker,
beste, Box-Midi-Sensor auch, oh, Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel,
Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel
Ruggel, Ruggel, Ruggel.
Aber den kann ich dir jetzt nicht geben, es ruckelt oder, Leute, 60 Sekunden...
Obei, ne?
Geht eigentlich oder?
Ihr müsst wirklich mal jetzt genau gucken, weil mir ist
Ahja, reckt. Mir ist Window-Aufnahme viel lieber als das
geht
Ich lasse hier meine Vorschau mal an
Warum hat man eigentlich keine gescheite Ping-Anzahl? Ach doch, oben rechts
Minimal? Wir probieren das mal anders aus
Ich mach mal das Setup, wo ich auf jeden Fall weiß, dass es nicht ruckelt
So hier weiß ich, dass es nicht ruckelt
Wir haben schon das erste Objective. Ich bin einfach einmal reingespotten und gestorben. Wie kann das sein? So, huge, huge
Oder der macht Shotgun-Challenges
Der macht Shotgun-Challenges. Ich wusste es, Leute. Ich habe es prediktet. Ich habe es prediktet, die machen jetzt alle diese dumme Weekly-Challenge
Und jeder und jeder rennt mit einer dummen Shotgun rum. Das war so klar
Das war einfach
obviosly
Der Bruder von... Nein, ich mach den Witz nicht. Der ist so schlecht
Oh, hier ist aber ganz schön was los
Ich höre die Shotgun-Dudes. Oh, Shotgun. Oh nein, die Shotgun-Challenge. Please, come on, da ist keine Shotgun-Challenge
Die Shotgun-Challenge
Okay, mal gucken, wie lange ich das ertrage heute
Clearly outplayed, ja
Wo sind sie? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wo sie genau stellten, aber
Der Shotgun-Dude, mann
Habt ihr den Shotgun-Dude gesehen, wie er einfach geschotgun-hunt across the map?
Oh nein
Oh, da ist er down, da geht er down. Einfach mal, einfach mal weggesprayt, alles, alter
Aber der Shotgun-Typ, einfach mal komplett durchs ganze Gebäude geballert
Ich fass es nicht. Wie, wir haben nicht, wir haben nicht die Legehände gemacht?
Ich spiel gerade die Legehände, ich spiel gerade die Legehände
Wir haben nicht die Legehände gemacht?
Ich spiel kein DMR, DMR ist nichts. Schneiber, alles, was nach Schneiber auch nur riecht, spiel ich nicht
By the way, oh, äh, by the way, nicht by the way
Ähm, ja, es ist so nice, sehr viele Deckung hier, exquisite, exquisite Deckung
Guck mal, ja, w-w-wieso, ok, pass mal auf, Massive, Massive-Five-Hat-Time
Massive-Five-Hat-Time, die sehen mich nicht, ihr seid Kacknoobs, ihr seht mich nicht
Aha, outplayed
Warum ist denn hier eigentlich ein Aus mitten auf der Map?
Übrigens, ich kann immer noch nix richtig zuordnen
Oh, PP-Gar aimed, das ist Todes, man
Alter, ich hör hier fünfmal Gegner vor mir, hinter mir, sonst wo, Alter
Ok, hat nicht gereicht, alles klar
Zu viel, zu viel, das ist ein AAA-Game, ja, das ist ein AAA-Game, ähm, mit, glaube, drei oder vier Entwicklerstudios
inklusive outgesourcetem Kram, Millionen-Budget, ähm, mit, ich glaube, drei oder vier Entwicklerstudios
inklusive outgesourcetem Kram, Millionen-Budget, ähm, einem, einem kleinen Indie-Publisher
Wo sind wir denn hier eigentlich?
Und die Seine, deren Gefühle man nicht verletzen darf, ja, so ist es, sag mal, es kann doch nicht sein, dass wir hier nicht Gelegehähne hinkriegen, oder?
Das wäre es jetzt, ja, nicht die Legehähne hinbekommen
Come on, game
Also, ohne Legehähne geht ja hier mal gar nix
Nice, nice, spawn
Ah, ja, äh, ich erinnere dich gleich nach der Runde
Sag mal, ist jetzt wieder ESL-Match angesagt heute
Ich hab ein cooles Video gesehen von Tom Hennerson, das ist der, der Oberleaker, was Battlefield angeht und so
Da muss man echt sagen, dass, also ich hab's noch nicht komplett geguckt, aber ich hab so ein paar Ausschnitte mir angeschaut
Das trifft, also das spiegelt so das ganz gut wieder, was falsch gelaufen ist in der Entwicklung
Oh, wir haben's verloren
Wir haben lost, Alter
Lost, xDxD
Was ist hier los?
Oder wie losten gerade?
Der bezahlt, nee, ich glaub nicht, dass der bezahlt ist
Wenn der bezahlt wäre
Okay, Alter, ich werd auf jeden Fall gekillt, wenn ich hier
Okay, keine Chance, machst du nix, einfach alle Gegner voll im Haus
Keine Chance
Aber macht nix, für erste Runde ist ja in Ordnung
Dann nehmen wir hier gleich mal ihn hier an
Ich, äh, du kannst nachjoinen
Wenn das geht, ansonsten lade ich dich ein
Das ist, das ist genauso ein Indie-Game wie die letzten Blizzard-Spiele
Ey, das mit der Shotgun ist ätzend, ja
Ich will eigentlich die Shotgun-Challenge gar nicht machen
Die Musik passt doch gut dazu, oder?
Nachdem das Spiel selbst keinen Soundtrack hat,
Kaleidoskop, da können wir uns mal angucken, ob die Rush-M-Coms auch besser platziert sind
Nämlich jetzt nicht mehr oben auf dem Haus
Also wenn ich die Shotgun anlocken will, dann geh ich einfach mal kurz Kaleidoskop versus Bots und unlock schnell die Shotgun
Was, die sind noch oben?
Wie, haben die wirklich bloß Breakthrough umgesetzt und nicht etwa die Rush-M-Coms?
Ey, das wird mich jetzt aber nicht wundern, ehrlich gesagt
Äh, wo ist denn unser, was ist denn das Ibe-Jewel?
Hat es nicht funktioniert mit den Joinern, oder?
Oder was ist da los? Irgendwie buggt?
Ja gut, die Frage ist eigentlich, die man stellen müsste, was funktioniert eigentlich, ne?
Die Chance, was zu finden, was nicht funktioniert, ist auf jeden Fall größer als was zu finden, was funktioniert
Oh, mal den Sensor rauskloppen und jetzt werden sie gebashed, Alter, jetzt werden sie richtig gebashed
Du Sixty!
Fuck
Ich hab's probiert, ich bin mal reingesprungen
Partyführung wählt das Spiel
Ach ja
Ey, verlass mal die Party und join mal neu rein
Äh, ich glaube, das buggt einfach nur krass rum
Das wird bestimmt gleich funktionieren
Und jetzt springe ich nicht mehr rein
MonkaS, das sah grad einfach mal aus wie ein...
Das sah einfach aus wie ein Gegner
Komisch
Wo haben wir hier was?
Ne, ne, ne, ne
Nicht raufkommen, Leute, nicht raufkommen
Nicht raufkommen
Joa, gut, das sollten wir hinkriegen
Ich seh keine Gegners
Außer, dass da unten ein Auto rumkurft
Ah, hipfire SMG
Was, disarmed?
Seriously?
Ach, come on
Du, du, du, du
Lennox, danke für den Zap
Ein Sponsor, ein Sponsor
Alter, Monka, Monka
Okay, wenn die's clever machen, flanken die uns
Die flanken uns, garantiert, ich werde mit euch
Die flanken uns
Okay, oder auch nicht
Hätte wetten können, die flanken uns
Okay, jetzt kommt hier einer gleich
Oder nicht
Könnt ihr euch mal entscheiden, please, Gegners?
Oh, oh, oh
Oh, sorry, ich wollte nicht so laut ins Mikrofon krachen
Was, was jetzt?
Och, komm
Nice, wir sind wieder am Start
Wir mussten echt weg
Also, es ist richtig schwitziger geworden jetzt
Wo die Playlist nicht mehr am Hauptmenü empfohlen wird
Okay, jetzt müssen wir hier aber zackisch
uns zackisch mal ranstölzen
Okay, die Hipfire Accuracy ist krass
Die Hipfire Accuracy ist wirklich heftig mittlerweile
Oh, ein huge Raz
Massive Raz, Massive Raz
Oh, da hinten sitzt noch einer, okay, okay
Hinten ist noch einer
Irgendwo hier
Oder auch nicht
Wait, wait
Ich fasse es nicht, man
Okay
Da hat mich vorher einer gehitted, der muss mich nur noch ins Bein bürsten
Äh, wo ist denn das M kommen?
Ich bin verwirrt
Wo liegt denn noch mal das M kommen jetzt?
Ist das gar nicht hier drin?
Äh, wo ist...
Ach, da hinten
Die diffusen
Fuck
Oh, die Shotguns, Alter
Da oben ist ganz viel, da kannste nicht hin
Da ist ganz, ganz viel, direkt am Eingang
Jetzt, jetzt
Äh
Ja?
Oh, das wird heute Auto-Shotgun-Fest
Ich sags euch
Da wird geschottet ohne Ende
Outplayed-Counter, aber richtig
Sowieso was von Outplayed die ganze Zeit
Ich frag mich, was
in den Köpfen von DICE vorgeht
eine Shotgun- und DMR-Challenge
zu machen
Also ist es nicht schon abfuck
genug
Pass mal auf, Bunnyhopping
Okay, jetzt wird's schwierig
Jetzt kommste eigentlich nicht mehr rein über die offenen Maps
Nicht mal gescheit
Wir müssen jetzt theoretisch wieder hier rauf
und hoffen, dass da oben keiner ist
Wir haben nämlich schon noch 10 Stück
Wir sollten jetzt nicht sterben
Sterben wäre jetzt ganz schlecht
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, wo die sind
Okay, nice
Fuck man, die sind
von hinten
Ich hab auf die Pistel geswitcht
Das Game hat's nicht gemacht
Rauchgranaten, ach was
Wir haben geahmt
Jetzt müssen wir nur noch defenden
Was aber schwierig ist, weil da vorne
Nee, das wird nichts
Ich glaube, Rauchgranaten sind tatsächlich
eine super Idee
Weil
die Smoke genervt ist
Äh, ich laber an Scheiß
Leute, ihr wisst, was ich mein
Weil
Was?
Äh, was?
Unser M-Commando
noch gar nicht entschärft
Oder haben die entschärft
Oder wie, oder was, oder hä?
I don't know
Guck mal hier
5 Firekills
Wichtigste
Was wurde mit dem neuen Patch
alles so gemacht
Ich hab ja grad die Patchnotes
vorgelesen
Das Wichtigste ist
dass die Hit Registration
angeblich besser ist
dass die Waffen an den Fahrzeugen genervt wurden
und dass
es ein bisschen weniger Spread gibt
bei den Waffen
Das war's so im Großen und Ganzen
Breakaway
Übrigens
wenn euch was auffällt
Wir sind permanent Attacker
Das bedeutet
die haben es noch nicht mal hinbekommen
dass man in Rush
die Seiten wechselt
Was auch ziemlich
a Fail ist
Muss man sich mal vorstellen
Also ein
Slot hätt ich noch
Haben wir hier irgendjemand on?
Ja
GG Eats
Es gibt auch keine Hin- und Rückrunden
Richtig, ja das war einfach zu schwierig
zu programmieren
Das kann man von so einem kleinen Indie-Entwickler
natürlich nicht erwarten, das seh ich auch so
Ist eigentlich Indie im Lautstärke okay?
Müsste eigentlich ganz gut passen, ich hab's so eingestellt
wie das letzte Mal auch schon
Okay ich renn jetzt einfach hier
und stell's mich aufs Dach
Fertig
Okay ganz so geil ist
Mein Hinlegen funktioniert nicht Leute
Hinlegen ist broken
Ich kann hinlegen
Okay wo stellst du so rum?
Oh ich hab tatsächlich
ein Gegnerlaufenhörn unter mir
Pork alter
Pork
Richtig Pork, das war
das krasseste
China-Chinesen-Aim aller Zeiten
aber ich hab ihn getroffen
Man hat das Game tatsächlich mal für Sound gelobt
richtig
Warum ist er nicht gestorben?
Angeblich wurde doch die Hit-Rack
verbessert
Oh das ist ganz schön blöd
ich sollte mal wieder aufs Dach
Ahja, ahja, exellent, exellent
Ah sehr gut
Shotgun
Oh das wird aber toll heute
wenn wir permanent von Shotgun outplayed werden
Oh wurde ich gerade gerätzt?
Kann das sein?
Oh da oben hier geht's ab
Rein da, rein da
Gib ihm
Oh ne wir müssen uns irgendwie defenden
Fuck
Ich smoke's einfach mal
meinen Leute ein
Wir haben's
Ok, so krass
ist das Hipfire doch nicht
Ich wollt's jetzt einfach mal ausprobieren
weil die haben ja gesagt Hipfire verbessert
aber so krass ist es dann doch nicht
dass du durch die ganze Lagerhalle Hipfiren kannst
Spawn ich mal neu?
Ja ich spawn mal neu
Nice
So wir haben's geschafft
Wait a minute hier ist so
Da
Hier sind doch bestimmt noch mehr oder?
Ja das mit den Motion Sensoren war schon mal
richtig gute Idee
Guck mal ich hör hier rechts was Leute
Oh ne links
Die waren rechts
Ok das funktioniert
behalten
So die denken jetzt ich komm da her
Big brain time
Kann ich da nicht retzen
Alter
Wo liegen sie denn?
Also hier geht ganz schön was ab gerade
Ganz schön viel los
Komm wir gehen
Wir gehen
Kurz schauen was hier los ist
Die werden weggespray die Jungs
Ich versuch dich zu holen
Ne
Ja nice nice nice
Oh guck mal da
Die massive huge IQ Plays
Huge IQ Plays waren das grade
massive von meinem Team
Alter was ist mit meinem Team noch warum sind die so
warum sind die so hoch intelligent heute
Die sind richtig krass
hyper intelligent
Pif Head
Eleven Head Alter
Oh oh ihr seht mich nicht Leute ihr könnt mich nicht sehen
Unmöglich dass ihr mich seht
Ihr könnt mich nicht sehen das geht nicht
Impossible
Impossible mich zu sehen
Ah ja ja wie ist es mit dem neuesten Patch
Ja
Geht
Geht geht
Moin an der Serial
Aber die Probleme sind natürlich immer noch da
Oh shit shit shit
Zu viel
Oh oh
Nein nicht oh
Mom get the camera
Aber die werden jetzt gebashed
Oh wir müssen ja noch A holen
Ich Dab Alter
Ich denk die ganze Zeit
Mann ich denk die ganze
Oh oh lass mich lass mich los
Lass mich in Ruhe
Haha das hast du so gedacht
Wir müssen ja noch A
Ich dachte die ganze Zeit wir sind jetzt schon durch
Wir sind jetzt schon durch
An was ist der gestorben
Ich hab keine Ahnung
Ich wills gar nicht wissen
Ich will einfach nur weg hier
Leute da sieht man mal wieder 16 vs 16
Leute 16 vs 16
Das ist einfach beste
Oh
Oh oh
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher von wo
Alles klar Game Danke
Vielleicht schaffen wir es noch
So jetzt wird das mal geschmockt
Massive Schmock
Und auch mehr Schmock
Boris
Pepega Boris
Alter an was kreppeln der dude
Was aber alter
An was kreppelst du mann
Ja klar an der smoke hat er hat er sich am smoke wirklich gekreppelt gerade
hat er sich wirklich am smoke man kann übrigens angeblich sich auch am motion sensor kreppeln
ich habe kaum smokes gespielt ich habe kaum ich habe kaum smokes gespielt es sind back na geil gut
dass so back schnell behoben wenn hip fire kills easy clap clone wars hier guckt euch an
so wir spielen jetzt noch eine runde diesen rush und dann probieren wir mal aus den diesen rush
modus der angeblich über alle spiel spiele geht die in portal sind ich frag mich nur ob das mit
specialist ist oder mit den jeweiligen fraktionen aus dem spiel weil das wäre ziemlich doof dann
habe ich keinen bock das zu spielen weil die sache ist die bed company 2 und battlefield 3 ist nicht
gut gemacht in portal mit den aus dem spiel das ist blöd ist nicht gut gemacht und so blöds
klingt battlefield 2042 specialist specialist ja ich kann dich annehmen hier wo bist du
welcher welcher davon bist du hier annehmen
wir starten auf dem kran so dass die beste map für webster grappling hook stellt das problem
ist auch dass ich finde das ist die schlechte ich finde es ist die beste battlefield 2042
map aber ich finde es die schlechteste rush map das musste erst mal schaffen oder es sagt
schon viel aus das war ein bisschen schnell no pass ich möchte ich muss warten bis man
grappling hook wo wo ich habe ein bisschen lang an einem fleck gestanden das stimmt schon wir
haben gelegt lege henne die lege henne ist am start hock hock gelegt
oder ist boris boris ist da unten am start
ok mit die fänden den kram jetzt einfach mal
das teuch ist so verbackt man ist hier kommt man nicht rüber ich gehe ich gehe den der
ist geschudet da kommen 50 milliaren gegner sagt ich muss hier kurz raus wir outen rufen
jetzt einfach aufs dach nein man game please warum bist du rumgebackt das wäre richtig
big brain gewesen aber es ging nicht ist rüber gesprungen ja das leichen rum labern ist tatsächlich
sehr irritierend
nice kommen wir schaffen es jetzt wird massiv diffused kann man hier hoch das ist das klappt
nicht so gut wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe ich muss auch kurz warten bis mein grappling
hook wieder am start ist dass ich die seite wechseln kann falls es geht kann man die seite
wechseln nein fuck geht nicht aber so oder um geht was da unten da unten sind 50 50.000
gegner alles klar da ist gd
so nebel ein eingenebelt hier
lege henne lege henne was hat mich gekillt eine shotgun hat mich gekillt ja wer hätte
das gedacht leute das wird heute ätzend ich sag's euch das wird heute schrecklich mit
der shotgun aber wir sollten der diffused leute ihr müsst da bashen alter ich bin ich
kann mich nicht bewegen nein nein ein kollege so das ist 16 16 dafür ist schon ganz schön
klasse da fang endlich stupdok eingeladen dann werden es zum triple a titel geworden
es ist ja ein triple a titel aber ein schlechter triple a titel und mit stupdok hätten sie
wenigstens einen gehabt der permanent im graben ist und im kreis läuft ich wollte eigentlich
messern aber die ganzen shotguns ist es wirklich ätzend
oh pepo fett leute pepo fett die gehen wir ja voll auf den sack egal wo du hin guckst
heute wirst du irgendwie angeschossen ich baller einfach mal in die richtung richtig pepo fett
nein pepo fett so da smoke da smoke alles smokes ok kein smoke wir haben geahmt leute
während ich hier oben auf dem auf dem kran rum stellse wird unten die runde gewonnen
so muss das sein so mag ich das jawoll gebe ihm
ist das moment mit der shotgun mit der shotgun von der straße aus moment moment was haben
die für eine range das heißt ich sollte die mal schnell anlocken oder wie
hier gehts mir gerade ein bisschen viel ab
ich komme so nackig vor ohne motion sensor da weiß mir gar nicht mehr wo was ist was
eigentlich gut ist weil er haben schalldämpfer wieder irgendeinen sinn
ok wo ist hier was da hinten ok schnell nein lass mich in ruhe nein nein nein nein so nicht
boxen zauen boxen so wie man das in echt halt macht erst mal den zauen weg boxen
die waffe ist auf diese range nicht gedacht unter mir leute unter mir pass mal auf da
gehen wir jetzt rein da gehen wir rein jetzt gebashed von hinten
seid ihr blind ob sie waren die blind oder was ziviert
pass einfach an mir vorbei gestellt der du ich habe keine ahnung wo der her kam der
war zumindest ein wenig ein wenig verwirrt der kerl
hallo ich würde gerne wiederbeleben dankeschön das so gut funktioniert ok ich smoke jetzt
einfach mal dahin ok jolo jolo draufsprayen wunderbar ok jetzt natürlich die große frage
was geht hier drin geht hier überhaupt was ich sehe nix aha da ist das m com ok ich
beeil mich die haben das ehrbild oh gehst du fort da unten ok sag mal kurz sich verpissen
die kommen jetzt hier alter hier ist viel zu viel los sprühen und beten ist angesagt
ja sprühen und beten mit dem trommelmagazin frage frage und frage ich bin mir nicht so
ganz sicher ach wir haben es oder was haben wir shotgun du ok ich weiß jetzt schon dass
mich schott ganz heute extremst abfacken wenn du überall damit rechnen muss dass einer
im nahe kampf dir gleich in die ins gesicht zwölf zwölf ne das er nicht zwölf milimeter
und wie nennt man das kalibe von der shotgun eigentlich irgendwas mit zwölf zwölf gauze
oder so gauze gauge zwölf gauge ins gesicht gottsch da wieder gucken wie man das ausspricht
ja shotgun wegen weekly korrekt korrekt deswegen finde ich so eine weekly challenge auch ziemlich
beschränkt es ist aber wirklich nice die gegner mal so ansatzweise zu hören gage wird
gesprochen ok gage zwölf gage hier weiß er wieder bescheid aber alle ja alle alle wieder
beleben sie wegen der daily das ist auch cool aber die shotgun die shotgun daily nein nein
nein nein dann nicht heute ich sag euch was scharl an hau oh nice nice nice poggers
wo müssen wir denn überhaupt hin bin voll verwirrt bin voll verwirrt man merkt also
ich merke voll das schon wieder eine woche oder so nicht gespielt habe aber ich will
eigentlich ich will eigentlich gar nicht spielen aber heute hatte ich mal bock ausnahmsweise
mir das anzugucken der panzer ist useless geworden ja zum glück der hat mich auch abgenervt
was ist mit dir da los nicht viel achtung nein nein wir gehen jetzt aufs dach dach
dach dach nein bittet bitte was bitte was das war die ganze das war die ganze die ganze
shotgun ladung ins gesicht und vorher hat er nichts getroffen ja dach war nix dach
dach war schlechte idee ja ich hab nen scharl an weil ich husten muss mir der hals weh tut
oh fenske fens fens fens fens dage
fädel ich hol dich ich hol dich ich scheiß scheiß drauf auf selbstil ich kann dich nicht
wiederbeleben du steckst du steckst im in der wand oh nee ich durfte ich nicht wieder
beleben durfte ich nicht wiederbeleben war war nicht erlaubt
die disabled alter was ist hier los mit shotguns und lsg mann aber die runde geht auch gut
rein oder wieviel das hammer acht das ist eigentlich relativ nice nein nein dann wird
die fuuske gemacht ich hänge jetzt einfach überall ein git ran und hoffe das klingt
irgendwie als wüsste ich wovon ich rede oh nee hinter mir i get fucked up in the ass
allwah hier
Aas, wer braucht Aas? Komplett useless.
Aas, overrated, outdated, G-Baded.
Massive G-Baded, okay, pass auf, Leute, ich versuch's.
Alter, Monka Corona. Okay, jetzt guckt euch das Haus an, in dem Haus sind einfach alle.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ist denn das Dach überhaupt hier? Ah, jetzt hier, nein, nein.
Ah, shit, shit, shit.
Das hat wieder mit dem Hook nicht funktioniert richtig.
Okay, jetzt aber, das IBUW geht ab. Gleich haben wir's, Leute.
Oh man, da hin ist er, shit, shit, shit, shit. Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck. Das hätte, das hätte
so gut, hätte, hätte, hätte, hätte es reingehauen jetzt. Dachke, Setke, Setke, Dachke, genau,
fast langsam dreh ich durch im Kopf, ist vorbei. Setke auf dem Dachke, man. Noch mehr Dachke.
Dachke, Dachke, Dachke. Selfhealge, nein, nicht in the ass, fucken, please. Ja, ist
ja gut, man. Dreh, dreh, dreh, dreh durch, geh. Okay, Prager, Leute, wir müssen es irgendwie
packen, wir haben nicht mehr viele Tickets. Wir haben nicht mal viele Tickets. Und die
sind wieder gestackt mit 16 Mann im Haus. Wir haben nur noch, wir haben nicht mehr viele
Tickets. Okay, 19, das geht sogar noch. Überlegt euch mal, es sind jetzt nur 16 Leute in dem
Haus. Oder wie viele sind es eigentlich heute? Sind es 16? Leute, ihr habt bestimmt gezählt.
Aber wir haben auch Lever. 16 Leute im Haus. In dem gleichen Haus oder neben dem gleichen
Haus ist, ich glaube, eine Breakthrough-Capture-Point. Ach ja, 15 vs. 17? Wait a minute. Können
die nicht mal richtig zählen? Zählge. Okay. Oh, oh, vor mir, vor mir. Oh, oh, von der
Seite. Ausgerechnet da fliegt eine Granate hin. Shit. Nee, es ist Player-Limit, richtig.
Oh, ich kriege einen Massive-Rest. Oh, hat die mich geboxt? Ach nee, ich bin ja voll
ins Ironside reingeflogen. Okay, kann ja mal passieren. Komm, 30 Kills die Runde kriegen
wir dann auch voll. Nein. The enemy has won. Tja. Zählge. Granate, Zählge, Dachge, Breakge.
Too easy. Habt ihr das Concept Art gesehen von dem normalen Battlefield 2042 Sturmsoldat
bevor Specialist drin waren? Das sieht richtig gut aus. Mal gucken, ob ich euch das zeigen
kann. Wartet mal. Concept Art Classes. Ja, das da, das meine ich. Ich zeig's euch einfach
im Firefox, weil der Firefox lädt YouTube-Videos nicht automatisch. Ja, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob das der Sturmsoldat ist. Nein, du sollst es nicht automatisch laden. Genau. Ich finde,
das sieht viel, viel besser aus als die ganzen Specialist. Das sieht in irgendeiner Art und
Weise wie halt so ein normaler Soldatstelz-Typ aus. Ich mein, was ist besser, das oder Boris
als Weihnachtsmann? Das sieht halt einfach nicht lächerlich aus, genau. Ah, Orbital.
So, Orbital muss man obelings landen. In der Hoffnung, wir sind schneller. Oh Mist,
das war jetzt Zeit verloren. Oho, da ist er in die Luft geflogen, würde ich mal sagen.
Shit, ich kann heute irgendwie nix zielen, gescheit. Schau mal, ich hab wieder voll
vorbei geschossen. SVK geht, aber das kriegen wir hin. Wir könnten übrigens mal wieder
auf die MP9 switchen, die ist auch ziemlich nice. Alter, please, lass mich nicht spawnen
und sterben. Ich brauch Motion Sensor, Leute. Ohne Motion Sensor hast du ja echt überhaupt
keinen Durchblick. Achtung, Stelzke. Bunny Hopke, sowohl. So, wir sind durch, Leute,
wir sind durch. PS Noob Revive. Okay, Sprague. Keine gute Idee, keine gute Idee, Leute, gar
keine gute Idee. Ich höre über mir, was? Was zum... Ey, der Soundchebatet ist ja mal
hardcore, Alter. Das Soundchebatet ist ja mal krass. Das ist ja fast noch schlimmer
als vorher. Ich hab den ohne Scheiß auf dem Berg gehört die ganze Zeit. Es sollten keine
Lacks geben mit FPS. Ah, Moment, ich muss Game Capture machen, nicht Display Capture.
Sorry, Leute, deswegen hat's geleckt. Also, auf der Seite bin ich noch nie durchgekommen.
Kann man mal ausprobieren. Hallo? Nein, Game. Big Brain Plays, denied. Keine Big Brain Plays
erwünscht. Kann man hier durch? Der Felsen ist neu, oder? Ich glaub, der Felsen ist neu
an der Stelle. Also, sie haben auf jeden Fall ein bisschen was getunt. Bin mir nicht ganz
sicher, was sie getunt haben, aber die haben auf jeden Fall irgendwas getweekt hier an
der Geschichte. Ich bin noch nie über die Seite reingekommen. Ich versuch euch mal zu
holen. Hier kommste nicht durch. Kannste komplett vergessen, Alter. Kannste komplett vergessen.
Das ist aber schon wieder echt halbes ESL-Match heute. Ist das ein Feature, dass du automatisch
springst nach dem Revive? Wahrscheinlich. Frag mal mal DICE. Ich ruf mal kurz in Schweden.
Frag mal schnell. Guck mal, wir sind da dran. Drange sind wir. Ach, fuck. Nein, nein, da
steht einer. Kann es sein, dass wir diese Runde hardcore krass auf den Sack kriegen?
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
Running low on cuties, so sieht's aus. Guckt euch mal das Team an, Lul, dass wir wieder
am Flame sind. Oh, was ist hier los? Guck mal da. Au. Ja, leider ist das komplett useless,
das Ding. Ich würde mich gerne vorwärts bewegen. Nein, nein, nein, wir fallen nicht
zurück. Nee, das kriegen wir nicht. Fuck. Alter, haben die irgendwas an, an, irgendwas,
das ist komisch. Das ist viel, viel schwerer als das letzte Mal. Was ist denn da los?
Die Arschleute spielen. Das merkt man richtig. Ich ziehe mal kurz raus und suche neue, Lul.
Einfach dodgen, einfach dodgen, wenn die Gegner zu gut sind. Guck mal hier, ein Spot Assist.
Huge. Hallo, ich möchte gerne raus. So bekommst du nie die Hexer Nuke. Ja, leider. Keine
Hexer Nuke. Aber die Moab vielleicht. So, dann suchen wir doch mal neu. Also, das sagt
hier ist Müll, weil es die Klassen aus dem jeweiligen Game sind. Das ist tatsächlich
Müll. Gun Master können wir jetzt dem Squad nicht spielen, da spielen wir noch mal ne
Runde Rush. Wir dodgen einfach mal kurz. Will nicht fragen, aber der Patch gut oder wie
der Müll? Ja, die haben schon ein paar sinnige Sachen gefixt, aber im Kern ist es immer
noch verbackt und kaputt. Zum Beispiel ist der Grappling Hook immer noch an Smokes. Hab
ich erfahren vorhin. Breakthrough ist spielbar. Das könnte man vielleicht gleich ausprobieren.
Ja, die Dachspots sind draußen. Stimmt, aber es ist ja oftmals schon so gewesen, dass es
gar nicht richtig das Problem mit Dachspots war, sondern dass man teilweise gar nicht
da bis hingekommen ist. Weihnachtsvibe. Ja, du hast Nintendo Weihnachtsplaylist. So,
jetzt wird Rush geläutert. Ich hasse die Steuerung dieser Fahrzeuge. Mein Güte. Lull.
B ist, finde ich, einfacher. Wir gehen jetzt... Ne, ne, ne, wir machen das anders. Game.
Ja, ja, ich hab's gesehen. Der Shooter shootet mir in der Ass. Fertig kann ich halt holen,
weil ich nicht weiß, wo der Du-Tennis ist. Okay, müsst jetzt. Okay, A sollten wir haben.
Ich würd sagen, lege Henne. Lege Henne auf B. Lege Henne auf B. Auf geht's. Ich zeig
euch jetzt mal Big Brain Spot hier drinnen. Passt mal auf. Okay. Passt mal auf. Leute,
ich muss Big Brain Plays machen. Ihr könnt mich jetzt nicht killen. Massive, Massive
Brain Plays. Das geht nicht, dass da Gegner irgendwie jetzt mitmachen, bis ich in Position
bin. Passt mal auf. Passt mal auf. Ich zeig's euch jetzt. Ich zeig's euch jetzt. Aber
erstmal muss ich da unten wieder rein. Es gibt den geilsten Spot überhaupt auf dieser
Map. Aber dazu muss man Big Brain sein. Bam, da sind wir, Leute. Bester Spot. Bester Spot
auf der gesamten Map. Leider bringt das gerade nix. Aber das ist der beste Spot, Leute. Da
guckt keiner hoch. Bester Spot. Massive. Huge high IQ Spot. Leider bringt der in dem Fall
gar nix. Vielleicht bringt er aber hier was. Gucken wir mal. Nein. Okay, wir bouncing von
der Decke. Aber an sich Massive Big... Geh weg, Haken. I see, Pfeil fährt. Ja, es ist richtig
Pfeil fährt. Normalerweise ist das massivster 5, 5 und 6 Cop. Oh, oh. Auto. Okay, man braucht
jetzt sogar Ammo Boxen, wenn man die mal richtig auf der Map erkennen würde. Man braucht Ammo
Boxen, damit man jetzt besser in der Ask shootet. Shotgun. Please. Diese Challenge, Mann. Ich
glaube, wir müssen die Challenge auch machen, Leute. Ich habe nichts unlocked. Ich habe
nichts unlocked für DMRs und ich... Oh, guck mal hier, wie man da herangestellt ist schon.
Vielleicht aufs Dach. Jawoll. TAX. GG Eats. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Nice. Next. Okay, wir machen jetzt einmal hier in den Launch Sensor. Nein, Moment, hat er
mich von hinten gehitted? Kann auch gar nicht sein. Unter uns, unter uns. Only 6 Head. Only
6 hat
Was hier doch moni moni next einfach mal schön ab campen hier
Okay, das funktioniert so nicht
Wo haben wir denn hat jemand irgendwie glorreiche idee wie man die
Munitionskisten auf der map besser erkennt
Ich check es nicht ich sehe immer keine munitionskiste ich check nicht ob das
Midi packs sind oder munitionskisten leute achtung
Exzellent
Okay, oh, da waren 50 gegner ich hab es genau gesehen
Oh nein
Fj danke für den zapp huske ja
Corona es
Damit hat jetzt nicht gerechnet dass ich zufällige der schreibt wall hack wall hack wall hacked
all hackt ok was auch immer
Ich vergaß es gibt ja kein all chat
Ehe dann doch nicht
So wo ist hier was next auf dem dach
Nein nein heli pisse ich
Ich
Bädel ich holt ich hoffentlich kommt der heli nicht
Die die dmrs die klatschen heute aber gut jeder jeder spielt dmr wegen der challenge
Monka es gel
In der s aber richtig in der s geschult hat den gesehen hat nur der pommel rausgeguckt
Ich würde gerne hier hoch springen wenn es erlaubt ist
Oh
Alles klar ich wäre schon längst in dem haus drinnen gewesen hätte es nicht geblockt
Erkennung gaming sagt ich finde dieses jahr dafür einfachen mit leider haben ich so hart auf das jahr ich habe mich auch
mega gefreut auf bettel viel ist halt
leider äußerst
äußerst enttäuschend
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher wer da was wie wo gehittet hat
Und die wurde gerätzt und schüss und wieder auf
Ok ich hole euch hol euch jungs ich hole euch ich hole euch
Das gds ist das anstrengend gerade warum ist es so anstrengend
Massive massiv anstrengend
Mlg das ist richtig hardcore mlg esl finals hier gerade
Stresske
Eslge ja leute es kann doch nicht sein dass keiner von team mir wieder am start ist und das mit diffusen
Die musik die musik ist optimal dafür geeignet ich könnte das nur noch toppen durch kirby gourmet race zehn stunden
Der typ macht übrigens seine kills seines lebens
Joinge Joinge
Was zum
Ah ich blick nicht mal durch zu viel monka monka es geht alter
Wie jetzt game lull
Ah
Das war hier wirklich esl finals
Wessen wetten wetten ich habe ich habe wieder hip fires
Wenn ich hab wieder hip fire seine oh nein leute besser noch besser dieses mal nicht etwa hip fire kills nein
sidearm kills
Also ihr habt gerade eigentlich eines der krassesten gameplays aller Zeiten hier erlebt mit vier sidearm kills
Also da könnt ihr jetzt euch nicht beschweren habt ihr zur richtigen zeit eingeschaltet
vier sidearm kills mann
Habt ihr zur richtigen zeit eingeschaltet vier sidearm kills mann
Albi jovel bist du raus also ich kann noch je nachdem wie viel platz wir haben gleich mal
Noch einen einladen
Ja einen können wir noch also wenn einer noch mitspielen will mal gucken wie es hier mit meinen leuten aussieht die eh schon am start sind
Der oberpeitscher der oberpeitscher will auch nicht
Das beste achten ist am längsten leben gibt es wirklich hatte ich glaube ich noch nie
Ist das für leute die nichts geschissen bekommen haben nicht mal einen assist kill oder was
Der friseur wie kommst du auf den friseur jetzt
Der freige hat leider kein bock mehr auf so games
Aber jetzt läuft flüssig wo ich hier umgeschaltet habe wieder oft game capture
Was sind sidearm kills dann mit der pistole? Saiten saiten armen
Ich weiß gar nicht wie wie sei wie übersetzt man sait armen
Sait armen
Sekundärwaffe alter der chat ist wieder so next level high IQ
Der chat ist wieder so next level high IQ
Outplayed ich liebe sowas massive park man
Oh ne ist der cool down des greifhaken so ein bisschen rauf könnte das sein
Die kommen doch hier hoch
Wer ist der friseur mein kumpel aus dresden mit dem ich früher videos gemacht habe der frazier
auch genannt xx der friseur xx hd
Ich höre gegner ok das hipfire ist schon krass
Oh werde ich jetzt gesplattert
Er schreckt mich doch nicht so
Ja motion sensor leute
Muni wäre nicht schlecht
Leute ich opfer mich jetzt einfach ich opfer mich jetzt einfach
Ich habe eh keine muni mehr
Ich glaube ich muss mich gar nicht opfern
Ich glaube wir packen es auch so
Das war ein hit
Game willst du mich rollen
Und auf gehts
Peepo fett
Sekunde leute
Ich muss leider ich muss kurz um schalten das geht jetzt nicht anders
Peepo fett
Jetzt geht's ok das kann ich jetzt zurückschalten
Dafür muss das muss jetzt aber sein
Leider leider geht kein desktop capture deswegen kann ich keine sinnlosen memes einplätzen
Lenden
Weil das game dann ruckelt das einzige game by the way was der meiner ist zu ruckeln
Ich hab's probiert ohne
Aha einer ist spawn
Was ist hier los
Der dude der weiß doch dass ich da bin
Ok ich hör was ich hör was unter mir
Ok das ist nice man hört die gegner
Da bin ich ich bin begeistert man hört die gegner das schon mal
Oh was ist denn da unter mir los
Was ist da unter mir los
Hier ist ganz schön ganz schön ganz schön was
Ich dachte hier ist er
Mein laufen ist gerade verbackt ich wackele die ganze zeit so komisch
Und meine muni ist all spawn bücken pieken op das mit dem hipfire ist krass ich hab's
gesagt bei den patch notes das ist die dinger waren eh schon mega heftig also smgs und auch
gerade hipfire smgs dass man jetzt auf die glorreiche idee gekommen ist das noch mal
noch mal zu buffen
Ja da ist logik keine ahnung big brain da ist logik ich weiß es nicht
Oh das hätte funktionieren können
Du würdest eine runde mitspielen erde mich erde mich einfach fj dann kann ich ihn weinen
Rein hier rein hier spawn op spawn bücken rein da nein
Könnt ihr nicht einfach disablen nicht nicht einfach disablen alter was ist mit euch los
Wait a minute wo sind die wo sind die stellst du hier hinten vielleicht
Okay ich glaube jetzt haben wir es
Von der anderen seite kommen sie
Guckt euch das mal von hier irgendwo
Erst mal kurz rüber stellzen
Damit habt ihr nicht gerechnet ne leute
Ich muss da rauf da muss ich rauf genau da muss ich rauf
Und wenn ich dann da rauf bin dann kann ich den nämlich in den kopf schuten
Deswegen mag ich webster einfach der beste specialist gerade für so vertikalen kram
Wer redet hier unten ah das sind die tippen die ich gekillt habe
Das heißt wir sind also alle die einen scoreboard sich wünschen sind einfach so also ich übersetzt
das jetzt mal ihr seid so hoffnungslos oldschool dass es eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr wert
ist für euch spiele zu entwickeln das ist gemeint mit legacy feature
Ihr seid quasi den letzten die letzten kack noobs wenn ihr an sowas hängt
Anders anders kann ich mir
Oh ich habe nicht reload okay ich habe nichts gemacht weder reloaded noch gedenkst
In den kopf mann
Der wollte mich shotgun habt das gesehen
der wollte mich shotgun
Okay lege henne
Sagen wir haben die wirklich gespawnt gerade die sind ernsthaft gespawnt direkt bei mir
die lege henne ist wieder unterwegs leute die lege henne macht mobil fack die lege henne
wird entschärft
Gibt ihm leute
Da wollte ich gar nicht hin aber okay nice die lege henne war erfolgreich leute biologische
Haltung
Wie nennt man das biologische gibt es biologische käfighaltung nie sowas gibt es nicht oder
biologische wie heißt denn das
Es ist nicht biologische anbau wie wie hält man lege hennen biologisch
Rheinland haltung ich wusste chat weiß das bodenhaltung genau
biologische bodenhaltung so sieht es aus
die einzig wahre lege henne ist unterwegs hier wieder
der chat ist feifett ja wir wissen ja auch woran das liegt dass der chat so feifett ist
weil es für jeden prime sub und für jeden sub ein IQ punkt für jeden im chat gibt und
das combined leute ist halt einfach mal der massive größte IQ 5 11 kopf den es auf twitch
gibt keiner hat so anderen also niemand auf twitch hat so high IQ chatter wie ich
das ist das ist ja auch erwiesen mittlerweile gibt es da schon studien zu
ich habe letztens den trosten sogar twittern sehen also ihr müsst immer eben auf twitter
gucken der hat gesagt wo bloß hat meistens feifett subscriber hat er direkt nach dem
letzten corona update gepostet und ihr sagt jetzt max das stimmt nicht guckt bei ihm
auf twitter werdet ihr überrascht sein max enjoyer ja ah nein nein ok jetzt ist natürlich
ein gutes problem ok feifett time was damit high IQ zu tun hat weiß ich nicht der ist
aber voll angesagt dem folgen viele leute auf twitter und wenn der das sagt weil wir
wissen ja dass gerade auf twitter es nicht um kompetenz geht sondern um viele follower
und das ist der heißt es eindeutig da muss da kompetenz sein jetzt mal ernsthaft was
er aber glaube ich auch wirklich ist wir können froh sein jetzt mal jetzt mal ernsthaft auch
wenn er viele flames und so was abkriegt wir können echt froh sein dass wir allen der
der größten experten auf dem gebiet direkt in deutschland am start haben auch auch wenn
er gerne übelst gehaltet das ist mal so zum gut ist zum guten ton gehört das zu halten
mittlerweile aber wer hat mir da ein erst geschütet
der ist doch nicht ernsthaft hier gesporned dafak der ist wirklich gerade mitten in diesem
haus gesporned wie es aussieht da war ein bieken das habe ich nicht gesehen dass da
ein bieken war oder fädel kriegt das in kopf geschütet und ich noch mal ok auch gut der
hat nur drauf gewartet der typ da oben
ok ich habe keinen plan was hier eigentlich genau abgeht aber wir werden sie bashen richtig
fädel ich hole ich unter uns in 50 milliarden gegner by the way da unten sind richtig krass
viele leute
oder auch nicht ich ich nehm zurück wir sind nicht so viele aber scheinbar nicht wir müssen
eigentlich gewonnen haben oder ja da ist hast du mich geadded wer auch immer gerade noch
mal joinen wollte irgendwas mit e am anfang zeigt mal fj ja da ist er angenommen
merkt man etwas vom patch dass man besser trifft
merkt man was dass man besser trifft
ich habe jetzt eine woche nicht mehr gespielt ich habe so dieses typische battlefield durchschießen
gar nicht mehr so im blut aber ich treffe genau ich treffe eh nicht also ich würde sagen
also wenn überhaupt ein bisschen zumal man halt ich spiele halt hauptsächlich hier auch
diese 16 vs 16 rush und da war es nie so ultra krass da müsste das mal 128 breakthrough probieren
die performance ist nicht wirklich bedeutend besser geworden
chat ich gucke mal kurz den chat durch weil ich bestimmt wieder irgendwas übersehen
alle alle warum leften alle was sie leute wie wir im kopf kann man eigentlich sein
um diesen satz zu bilden warum leften alle es gibt es gibt so sachen die ergeben einfach
keinen sinn warum leften die auch die leften weil sie predikten dass das game crashed
sonst sind sie sätge da müsste ich müsste mal hingucken ob man da so eine art gedicht
schreiben kann so immer ein deutsches und ein englisches wort abwechseln und es ergibt
noch einen sinn ein gedicht ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben dafür aber guck
mal da ist ein auch ein kagel ist da mini gandt hrq verwirrt ja die rage lefter genau
wir sollten rage quitter eindeutig ersetzen durch rage lefter rage lieber wäre ja noch
ok aber rage lefter ok nice nice high IQ spawn point oder oben da oben ein pass auf mich
und da oben war noch mehr habt ihr den schuss sound gehört noch nachdem der tot war ging
es ging es euch auch so oder kommt auto jetzt müssen wir hier ran leute wir müssen ran
oh weg gedienst alter wo ist der dann ist der rush modus dieses erzwungene englische
worterverwenden ist das ist nicht erzwungen das ist wenn ich nicht nachdenke dann bilde
ich so komische setze das ist nicht dass es absicht wäre oder so ich ich also ich sage
im prinzip eins zu eins das was sich in meinem kopf befindet und das sind so komische denglisch
setze ich bin einfach zu lang in der it und so lang im gaming unterwegs als dass ich
es noch wenn ich nicht wirklich nachdenke auseinander halten würde ok ich oho oho achtung
line of sight line of sight out move hier hey max lohnt es sich für battlefield eine
ps5 zu holen nein es lohnt sich finde ich aktuell weder eine ps5 zu holen noch battlefield
42 also beides doppelt nein doppelt doppelt no oder um es etwas genauer zu sagen solltest
auf gar keinen fall ist da oben einer ok achtung achten wir mal das denn ok so geht es schon
mal nicht kann man eigentlich hier das war jetzt alles nicht so nicht so schlau aber
nicht so schlauge ne ne ne ne ne ne kollege damit hast du nicht gerechnet damit hast du
nicht gerechnet ok ich kämpfe mir mal kurz hier ein ab oben bis wohin geht denn die grenze
aha bis da das heißt wir können noch gar nicht weiter pushen als da aber ich schmeiß
schon mal ein mauschen senso ein ok jolo seriously ok da hat es drauf seriously alter
oder war noch mehr ich hätte weiter schießen sollen aus der luft geschneibert ja richtig
krasser schneiber tut ich habe das gefühl die haben den grappling hoch ein bisschen
jetzt kommt mir zumindest ein bisschen so vor damit hast du nicht gerechnet dass du jetzt
die fresse geschossen kriegst ne ne ne ne alles klar was fährt da neben mir es ist
teilweise richtig also man muss sagen so im 16 was ist 16 hatte schon so ein paar coole
battlefield moments so das ist halt noch halbwegs überschaubares chaos deswegen beschwer ich
mich ja da auch gar nicht wenn man gekillt wird oftmals hätte man es ja vermeiden können
was halt bei 128 also 164 60 überhaupt gar nicht mehr der fall ist ok mal gucken ob das
noch funktioniert nein nein nein nein der shotgun dude nein das ist er und ich dachte
ich habe ihn noch rechtzeitig erwischt wir sollten es gleich haben denke ich wir haben
schon wieder lege henne gemacht aus biologischer bodenhaltung nix da also ich finde es gut
das ist tatsächlich eine erinnerung die ich gut finde dass der motion sensor jetzt dass
der motion sensor jetzt eben nur einfach vorhanden ist das ist für mich besser und und im prinzip
man gibt es dem gadget auch mehr value weil du es auch sinnvoll einsetzen musst so ist
das hier ein medipack ne ne das ist kein das ist das ist ein medipack da oben das ist keine
muni muni kiste ich kann es nicht richtig auseinander halten ihr könntet mir was geben
jungs machen sie wahrscheinlich der grappling hook ist richtig nice deswegen spiele ich
den auch am liebsten das ist so ein zusätzliches movement element was einfach spaß macht und
vor allem auch die map kenntnis ein bisschen zugute kommt ja muni muni muni einsammeln
perfekt muni guck mal hier das sind sie auf dem weg die ganzen kleinen stells aus da ist
natürlich nur einer kann man die waffen von anderen nicht aufheben doch noch schlimmer
ich könnte einfach mein magazin wechseln und ich hätte wieder muni da habe ich jetzt
überhaupt nicht dran gedacht einfach richtig massiv des ppega okay nein game das war so
nicht gedacht hx gg es game hallo hallo mit der ammo war das kein bug nein das ist absicht
guck mal ich habe jetzt 65 und ich switche jetzt und ab 128 das ist absicht das ist absicht
wenn ich sicher wo die sind gerade aber scheinlich über mir okay ich glaube wir haben es gleich
klar spiel alles klar easy ich bin der zweitgrößte battlefield streamer auf twitch das sagt schon
einiges aus oder über die popularität wie gut das angekommen ist diese sprüche man
wenn die kam gatschi buss ja sagt viel über das game aus wirklich so ja die balance ist
wirklich weird champ ich glaube wir spielen demnächst mal mittel bis in battlefield 3
wieder zur abwechslung welfil 3 spielt einfach komplett anders wie ist der patch naja mal
ehrlich so viel hat sich da nicht geändert die größten änderungen ist das angeblich
jetzt besser der hinterrack ist konnte ich noch nicht so wirklich feststellen bisschen
weniger recoil was für mich halt krass ist ich meine wir haben ja kaum hier eine ru- also
ich glaube seltene runde oder 20 kills und teilweise sogar deutlich mehr das wollte ich
jetzt sagen dass das hipfire der smgs noch besser gemacht wurden das finde ich fragwürdig
ja und das mit den updates habe ich halt auch in meinem video gesagt so nach dem motto ist
das noch battlefield die sache ist halt die du kannst halt die bugs schon fixen das machen
sie ja auch aber im kern so diese sachen mit specialist was ja viele überhaupt nicht
feiern oder 128 spieler und diesen offenen lieblosen maps also mich würde es hart wundern
wenn die die maps grundsätzlich noch mal überarbeiten wird also richtig richtig grundsätzlich
kann ich mir vorstellen wenn es andere maps ja ok nice und hipfire und hipfire war davor
schon krass ja das kommt ja noch dabei hipfire war krass und und ist jetzt und ist jetzt
auch mega wir machen mal ein motion sensor dahinter nein nein nein hat sich ausgemotion
sensort nein nein nein ach da sind noch mal fünf stück ok die habe ich nicht gesehen
fünf mal boris nee zweimal angel einmal boris wo ist der chat der in game chat das ist der
in game chat der aim assist soll auf der konsole sehr merkwürdig sein ja das habe ich auch
ach guck mal da guck mal da wer ist denn da oben wer ist denn hier nein game warum geht
der grappling hook nicht wenn ich ihn brauche was soll das warum ist das manchmal broken
ok was frage ich mich natürlich das ist broken so wie der rest des games wo käme auch dahin
wenn du dich irgendwie drauf verlassen könntest es einfach funktioniert kommt dir was rein
ich glaube wir gehen lieber hier lang von da vorne kommt aber richtig viel kann man
hier drauf worten ich brauche die map spiel ich brauche die map gott spiel geh halt wirklich
schlimm wenn jede zwei sekunden sagen muss eil geh halt mach halt mach halt das was du
eingebaut hast da war doch was oder ich habe bin ich wann es boomer augen oder war hier
nicht wirklich grad was chat sagt man schon spät boomer augen oder habe ich wirklich
was gesehen es war da nicht da der chat ist ja immer relativ schnell dabei zu sagen boomer
augen fettlich wollte ich holen es hat aber nicht funktioniert boomer omega alles klar
oder auch das zeroes max falls er da ist wenn ihr mitspielen wollt sagt bescheid ich check
hat nicht so genau wo die sind aber ok ok alles klar cool cool story jetzt aber man
ok ich glaube ich glaube jetzt alles der da jetzt natürlich die frage wie crossen wir
das jetzt war das war das grad ein rpg der einfach da an mir ultra vorbei geschrammt
ist enemy sported enemy sported enemy da sind aber viele enemies die gespottet werden
müssen ok ich habe so mein problem wie komme ich da rüber ok ich renne jetzt einfach
rennen jawoll jawoll oh ne hier ist ja keine deckung hier ist deckung exzellent exzellent
in den kopf aber der bruh mwp gibt es bei wenn ich noch server ja aber keine spieler
bunny hop zorn jawoll gib ihm by the way soll ich euch erklären wie man bunny hop oder ist
das allseits bekannt ist knowledge hau mal raus ist eigentlich ganz einfach ihr müsst
von oben nach unten kreppling hocken oder oder fliegen und dann einfach die tasten loslassen
ihr dürft nicht nach vorne drücken und müsst lehrtaste spam das war es ihr dürft nicht
weh drücken oder wer ist die ihr dürft nicht wer ist die drücken beim aufkommen und dann
einfach lehrtaste spam es ist eigentlich die einzig die einfachste bunny hop mechanic in
jedem game ich frage mich immer noch ob es ein bug ist oder ob das absicht ist so nutzlos
ist das gar nicht das ist tatsächlich äußerst praktisch in dem game der weiß dass ich damit
ich kann den ich kontest mit meiner smg ich komme nie raus alter hat er sich jetzt gehielt
ist ein feature gut ob der stat das war mal smooth smooth haben ich versucht von der seite
zu beschen kann man das hat personalized was was verstehst du unter personalized das hat
du meinst nicht eine playerkarte du meinst dass das ui aber wie wie ach du meinst dass
man die die position verschieben kann wo was ist nein glaube nicht habe ich nicht gesehen
aber noch einer shit ich bin ich bin der ich bin dead gerade vielleicht retzke nein gibt's
nicht respawn komm ah jetzt beschen alter beschen alter beschen ah muss gebäscht werden
ja sehr gut sehr gut das
pack den habe ich nicht gesehen boomer augen oder jefe besti runde aber richtig so muss
es sein immerhin immerhin einer carried uns easy easy carry das ist ein bisschen doof
darunter zu trotten mit dem pence mit dem pence man oh oh shit nein da unten sitzen
er wieder auch von hinten von hinten von hinten oh oh oh oh nein shit shit hier ist aber ganz
schön viel los gerade weg durch die neue ppega das stimmt überhaupt nicht lmg ist die neue
ppega das das pkp bp oder wie dieses ding heißt das ist das ist eigentlich die neue
ppega 29
ist planted leute massive planted ich muss darauf gucken auf den charge jetzt von wo überhaupt
nice huge fatal macht das ich muss meinen motion sensor da unten rein reinklotzen ich
habe keinen mehr shit na gut die runde ist wirklich in your face stream sniper leute ich
sag's euch nur stream sniper kappa stream snipen ohne server browser null geht das eigentlich
wie ist denn das wenn die warzone streamer gestream sniped ich meine die können eigentlich
auch nicht gestream sniped werden oder ist doch matchmaking oder drücken die leute einfach
zu exakt gleichen zeit matchmaking wie die leute im stream matchmaking drücken habt ihr
doch bestimmt erfahrung ihr wisst ja wie das wie das wie das ist
den warzone warzone streamer gestream sniped war ich jetzt aber nicht oder
ok letzte base gachi base
ich sehe nichts dank diesem tollen grünen eiken
nice gg sehr gut
ich bräuchte muni und ein von hinten in the bobs shit und jetzt bin ich gestackt im felsen
wahrscheinlich kann ich nicht wiederbelebt werden und wir sind alle dauernd die haben
uns ganz schön umzingelt wir haben ja jawoll nice es gibt kein storm scoreboard ne es gibt
nur dieses ding hier dass immer das fj gerade übelst abgeht so muss es sein einer im squad
muss immer carrying das kann sich ändern nach der runde aber einer muss es machen sonst
ist noch älter wo sind die alle sonst ist kein kein win no carry no win aber es ist
nice dass die alle diese diese challenge machen
nicht so ganz so habt ihr euch das net vorgestellt ok wir müssen weg hier wir haben es wir haben
es nice einfach nichts gemacht sinnlos rumgestanden easy ok die range hat nicht so ganz gestimmt
ich habe übrigens eh das gefühl dass der fall damage in diesem spiel sehr merkwürdig
ist das hat kaum fall damage gemacht und und zwei und sagen halben meter mehr bringt
ich quasi um den fall damage habe ich noch nicht durchschaut wahrscheinlich kann man
den nicht so gut durchschauen so wie vieles ok wie komme ich jetzt hier wieder raus einfach
so einfach wieder verpisst ja einfach weg also bis die deckung wäre halt schon cool
das ist glaube ich alles neu hier seit dem seit dem letzten oder vorletzten patch da
haben die deckung platziert auf den maps nein nein nein wehen macht er platt der panzer
mich alter fj was gehen ab gucken euch an gucken euch an alter hast jetzt den wallhack
eigentlich schon eingemacht oder wie oder was ist ja
man game sei doch nicht so verbackt echt wahnsinn echt wahnsinn echt wahnsinn man
wtf pass auf der kommt hoch ich sags euch ne das ist tot schuldig nein euch nicht max
hat gerät schritten über um soll ich welche 16 16 16 rush kann man halbwegs spielen zumal
wir den super krassen carry bei uns hier am start haben im team gerade das geld alter
warum rekt er die so krass guckt euch mal an seht ihr den kill feed man ist ja ist das
ist esl final der spiel um preisgeld gerade sagt euch preisgeld ist raus ey mein gott
was ist denn heute mit dem pack in krabbeling hoch los ich konnte nix machen der geht mal
richtig ab und wir schaffen es trotzdem nicht diese kacke einzunehmen man kann doch nicht
sein ok wo ist a das muss er erst mal hinkriegen ok jawoll lass mich rein hier kacibas gibs
mir ich will raus alle ich kann wieder net exiten weil es gern wieder verbackt ist also
ich bin gerade richtig abgefuckt weil das spiel nicht funktioniert mann was ist das
denn ich wäre jetzt oben und hätte den typ gekillt mit dem krabbeling hoch hoch und hätte
den typ gekillt also das ist jetzt so viel kacke hintereinander gerade erst kann ich
nicht aussteigen dann ist der krabbeling hoch nicht dahin gegangen wo ich hin wollte das
eben war halt blöd da bin ich drüber gesprungen das war meine schuld aber was ist das wieder
alle 54 der geht aber richtig rein diesmal wie heißt er auf dem imageport meines vertrauens
ich benutze kein imageport und wenn dann würde ich hier nix dazu sagen ich da heiße als nicht
umsonst anonym auf jetzt hier volle pulle gib ihm gib ihm nochmal diese waffe ist so
useless mann diese raketen sind so fucking useless ne letztes mk nicht gekriegt aber
am fj lags auf jeden fall nicht wir hätten übrigens gekriegt hätte krabbeling hoch funktioniert
garantier ich euch hätte ich aus dem auto aussteigen können hätte krabbeling hoch funktioniert
easy win und was haben wir oh parachute kills parachute habe ich skins unlockt
mal gucken ich anlock mir jetzt den den mckay mckay cowboy skin wo gibt's den jaja ich wollte
gar nicht raus das hat hier rumgebackt jetzt wäre ich gleich die fans oder so ein müll
die fans spielen wir gar nicht collection specialist moment wo kann man das überhaupt
einstellen ok leute ich weiß ich bin zu dumm die skin sechsektion zu finden das musste
erst mal schaffen dass ein ui so schlecht ist dass du den skin nicht findest so vielleicht
sind wir wieder attacker wenn ich gehe ich gleich raus und gehe wieder rein weil ich
will nicht die fans spielen die fans sagt wir können ein zwei runden die fans mal spielen
auf rush wenn es jetzt was ist aber danach suchen wir neu
ah ne wir sind mehr die fans ok komm 1 1 2 runden die fans können wir mal zur abwechslung
spielen aber dann ist gut die fans ist einfach kreppieren wir waren 42 rush ab we go ok ein
recht stamm alles klar pc specs ja ich glaube wir haben ausrufe zeichnen pc oder specs oder
irgendwas in der richtung haben wir glaube ich muss mal ausprobieren das ist auch zum
größten teil noch aktuell mein pc ist nicht sonderlich neu ich habe sie mich nicht eingesehen
mir neuen zu kaufen ok ne die fans sagt man die fans ist richtig richtig sätge pepega
oh ich habe
echt immer ein bisschen muni haben die schon haben die lege hände gemacht haben die schon
lege hände gemacht hoffe ja nicht keine lege hände für euch leute keine lege hände für
euch das war das motor geflasht nice was hast du geflasht was hast du geflasht steckdose
oder leds oder flasche flasche pass mal auf ich mache jetzt mein big brain meine big brain
posi hier ja lass mich durch muss durch hier big brain posi da kommt keiner hier auf die
idee sonst die posi packt manchmal ein bisschen kommen mehrere anläufe aber beste messer
pfeiffer 6 6 7 8 9 hat posi so jetzt habt ihr keine chance gegner keine chance jeder
der hierdurch kommt ist automatisch der big brain posi natürlich außer die kommen da
wo ich nicht stehe das natürlich durft ok ich muss raus
alles dauernd ich hole durch das gegner hat er nix gesehen hat gedacht macht geilen flank
stells weiter heute ich kann wieder nicht springen mein sprung button ist wieder verbackt
weiß ich weiß immer noch nicht wie ich das fixe gescheit also außer sterben sterben
kann man dann dann hat sich das von alleine gefixt vielleicht noch mal hier jetzt nee
jetzt gehts auch nicht ok das ist doof ich hab keine ahnung wie ich das fixe gescheit
ohne springen ist schon ziemlich dumm spiel deinstallieren selbst das hilft bei battle
viel nix mehr was ist denn hier los ich würde gerne auf
meinen ente hacken switchen ente hacken ente hacken ist auch so ein zelda ding kann ich
wieder auch ich kann wieder springen leute das hat sich selbst gefixt nice massive amobox
ok wir gehen wieder auf den massive play ihr guckt jetzt mal ernsthaft leute ihr guckt
doch keine sau hin oder du brauchst ffz oder better twitch tv das zeige ich dir gleich
also du hast zwei varianten aber ich würde dir das hier empfehlen ranker faces z das
brauchst du als browser emote als browser addons um die emotes zu sehen und dann eine
runde defense machen wir noch dann ist Schluss mit defense und dann musst du in den settings
noch alles anhaken was du haben willst animierte emotes better twitch tv emotes special emotes
keine ahnung was so alles gibt können hovercrafts immer noch an gebäuden hochfahren also des
letzten patch ging es noch und nachdem ich in diesen patch notes nix dazu gesehen habe
vermute ich dass es immer noch geht also ich tippe drauf ja können sie immer noch und
es war auch für die für die objectives erforderlich bisher dass das ging also auf our class auf
orbital und auf kaleidoskop wenn du eine halbwegs chance haben willst aber jetzt auf etel bist
weg aber jetzt könnte man das ausschalten du du du du du du du lefth joint die defense
machen wir noch danach suche ich mir wieder eine attacker runde weil die fans ist irgendwie
die q jetzt war es gar nicht so schlau haben die den haben die den cool down runter gemacht
mir kommt es fast so vor mir kommt es ein bisschen so voll ist der cool down runter was
ist hier los mein mein mein fallschirm ging nicht auf und ich bin nicht gestorben was
der doppelt pepega ist
mich schon auf ganz spezielle art und weise broken wo sind die sind die eher hier oder
eher da drüben ich würde mal sagen ich bleibe hier weil hier ist sonst keiner oder auch
nicht ich gehe mal da rauf ah pippo fett time pippo fett aufhören webster nicht so
pippo fett sein achtung massif res in der ask schudet kann man die vector ja die vector
macht mega bock vector kannst du gut spielen mp9 für mich persönlich auch meine lieblingswaffen
in dem game weil ich gerne spreie und präge im nahkampf wird da wird gesprüht guck jetzt
haben sie ah da ist einer das ist gar nicht so einfach etwas zu hitten ich brauche muni
jetzt gehen sie bestimmt auf den anderen gleich die gegner sind glaube ich fj mal gucken ob
ich rankomme bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher wo er ist oh nee richtig pepega von mir pepega
und den gegner pepega doppelt wow doppelt pepega kannst du bettel viel mittlerweile
ohne schlechtes gewissen empfehlen nein gar kein fall und es wird wahrscheinlich auch
nie der fall sein die shotgun dudes nee kann ich nicht empfehlen und ich glaube auch nicht
dass das dass das passiert ich habe den gesehen ich wollte aber erst mal ein teammate ratzen
ok vielleicht bleiben wir jetzt auf b weil wir a nicht mehr gescheit kriegen der anderen
seite es dauern ok so müssen wir aufpassen was da von oben angestellt kommt die sache
ist die ich habe nie diese unten als jetzt wieder richtiges esl match hier gerade ich
merke das sind die dais mitarbeiter ach das wegen auch dieser developer name verstehe
verstehe wobei den habe ich schon öfters hier gesehen ist quasi eingeschmuggelter
schwedischer da ist man
ich kann hier oben nicht bleiben ich kann hier oben nicht bleiben ich werde ich werde
weg pepega sobald ich den mann kopf raus schreck von wo
nicht der sound wenn der typ sich da hoch hoch denkt er muss auch gar nichts machen sein
grappling hook macht auch alles für ihn jetzt ist jetzt alles verloren jetzt dreht er durch
die runde wieder woher eigentlich der unkern konventionelle twitch namen kennen ich seit
2005 aber dein twitch ist mir nie in die auge gestoßen also die sache ist halt die er muss
den grappling hook festhalten stimmt die sache ist die ich habe mir den account erstellt bevor
ich selbst trieb sollen wollte und ich habe ihn nie wieder geändert und jetzt ist halt
die sache oder was mein ihr macht ich könnte ihn auf max fps ändern aber dann wissen ganz
viele leute auf twitch auf einmal nicht wer das ist das stimmt nicht aber es gibt durchaus
einige auf twitch die es nicht wissen und umgedreht wobei ich das mit wo bloß gar nicht so schlecht
finde weil die leute die ihren weg hierher finden zu wo bloß dingen da über die steine
für den sub die sind high iq und wir wollen ja prinzipiell nur high iq leute hier im chat
5 hat only ja die follower werden automatisch mitgenommen das stimmt aber wenn du dann online
gehst und es kommt auf einmal so eine komische meldung was die leute nix sagt casual gamer
danke für den sub dann sind die verwirrt und sind wir was sind wir was sind wir die
fans attack attack defense präge leute präge attack präge präge attack ist mein spiel
gecrasht hast du noch hier nice zu warten ja doch es gibt ein paar die wissen dass ich
das nicht bin der server dead oder passiert da noch was gibt es gibt es was wie wir können
die explosiv planten gibt es ein kommando disconnect oder so moment bf console disconnect
command
ist ok ich habe einfach mal alt erführt leute ich traue euch gleich wieder nach man eine ahnung
ob das einen disconnect command gibt in der konsole wäre sehr sehr praktisch aber es gibt
immer ein disconnect ich kenne keine game mit konsole das nicht in disconnects hätte
das nicht in der party ja ich bin in einer queue ok leute easy easy game wir müssen jetzt
mal schnell gewinnen in der zwischenzeit gucke ich mal ein bisschen chat ich habe bestimmt
die ein ein oder anderen sachen nicht nicht gesehen und ich beantworte also ich soll mal
kurz durch hier nach messages hast wie gesagt den nice button habe ich noch der ist noch
am start endlich high iq ja du musst aber eigentlich noch samen wenn du sabst ist noch
mehr high iq ja aber es gibt leute ich habe letztens mal gefragt die kennen mich nur von
twitch das liegt aber auch einfach daran ich habe relativ viele programmier streams technik
streams und was gemacht und macht das auch weiterhin in zukunft da gibt es leute die
finden dich halt auch ganz normal über twitch haxia danke für den sub ding dong dankeschön
machts game ist schon noch ja das hatten wir schon erklärt der rett ist nur schneller
wenn es maria falck ist oder ich weiß nicht ob angel auch schneller rett ich glaube nicht
kontakt zu kaboom schon eine weile nicht mehr gehabt ne
welche spiele freust du dich 2022 game releases 2022 aus dem kopf weiß ich gar nicht was da
alles rauskommt gucken wir mal
war nie gibt es da eben da ist es highlighted ok monster hunter juckt mich nicht rainbow
six dying light juckt mich nicht l ring bin ich mir nicht sicher ich bin ich so der große
dark souls man lx 2 könnte ganz nice werden gta 5 ganz bestimmt nicht tiny tinas wohl
ist das ein borderlands bin auf oder so vom namen her hört sich das so an die spieler
innen sind am start wieder stalker 2 ja da mal gucken ob das was taugt und schadet juckt
mich nicht jetzt irgendwie eine ordentliche übersicht lx das ist quasi gothic in der modernen
setting gibt das irgendwie best pc game releases 2200 kennt ihr eine gute übersicht open world
die open world juckt mich halt mal gar nicht diese überschrift immer alles so pepega nein
das ist kein anscheid das kommt nach anscheid collection gibt es nicht gibt es nicht immer
irgendwie eine ordentliche übersicht biggest best nicht best pc game releases wir hatten
dann schon übersicht hier pc spiele 2000 pc games hardware hast du die deutschen patch
notes gelesen nee was was steht da hast du die deutschen patch notes von battlefield
2242 da steht in einer zeile einfach ein fix für einen seltenen bug durch den spielende
für gegner innen unsichtbar sein konter gut das deckt sich ja mit dem wie es in game übersetzt
ist in game ist es jetzt ja auch scharf schütz innen und und spieler innen und was auch
immer aber ich finde das thema ist es eigentlich gar nicht wert da großartig drüber zu labern
auch wenn sich holprig liest da habe ich ja schon recht so allen ring mal gucken ich
bin ich so große dark souls fan aber gucken wir mal redfall sagt mir gar nix starfield
sagt mir irgendwas aber ich weiß gar nicht mehr was hogwarts legacy ja biggest game ganz
klar natürlich also was haben wir denn schönes 2000 nee nee nee nee nicht 2021 2022 brauchen
wir ok fester termin monster hunter god of war das werde ich mir auf jeden fall holen
brauche keine ps5 ps4 ich habe eine ps4 lull ich kann es eigentlich auf der ps4 spiele
aber spielst du immer auf dem pc juckt mich nicht juckt mich nicht juckt mich nicht juckt
mich nicht juckt mich nicht könnte mich vielleicht jucken juckt mich nicht könnte mich auch
vielleicht jucken juckt mich nicht könnte mich könnte mich interessieren wie mehr mehr
steht da noch nicht fest oder was das kommt im leben nicht 2022 leute ich sags euch es
wäre poggers wenns kommt kommt aber wahrscheinlich nicht der herr der ringe lull mal wieder die
lizenz melken oder was diablo 4 tja ganz ehrlich so große hoffnung habe ich da nicht drin
die siedler mal gucken ob das was taugt es gibt also die siedler haben coole teile also
es gibt wirklich gute spiele in der serie ich fand auch das 6er oder was das war ziemlich
gut aber auch schon ein paar jahre her so was haben wir sonst noch hellblade 2 in ersten
teil fand ich ganz ok so als story game aber der zweite interessiert mich nicht so sehr
kurbel space program was übrigens nichts mehr mit dem originalen zu tun hat neuer entwickler
und neues team und alles overwatch 2 jaja ganz bestimmt obs falsches overwatch 2 das
kommt doch ja auch nicht dieses jahr raus das kriegt doch blizzard wieder nicht geschissen
poe 2 sollte ja auch schon vor 500 jahren erscheinen ob das nächstes jahr rauskommt
fraglich shadow warrior 3 das interessiert mich tatsächlich ich fand shadow warrior
1 und 2 ziemlich gut ne kurbel space program ist nicht die gleichen entwickler das ist
das gleiche also der typ der das also die die das gekauft haben die machen jetzt teil
aber der ursprüngliche entwickler und die leute haben damit nichts mehr zu tun skulls
and bones das kommt doch auch im leben nicht das ist doch auch schon developer hell seit
vier jahren oder so so garantiert kommt auch nicht der star citizen single player also leute
glaubt wirklich glaubt wirklich jemand dass der star citizen single player 2022 rauskommt
leute wie schauts eigentlich mit dem game aus ist es fertig oder läufts noch
kommt im leben nicht raus juckt mich nicht system shock remake das könnte mich jucken
die waren ganz cool vor allem system shock 2 war mega nice witcher 3 next gen moment
witcher 3 gibt es jetzt aber auch dann wirklich für alle konsolen generationen der letzten
15 jahre oder die xbox 360 die ps4 also bleiben wir bei xbox 360 xbox one xbox series x tom
clancy xd5 tom clancy game das ist auch das wo ubisoft jetzt nft graben machen will ok
anscheinend kommt für den pc werde ich mir auf jeden fall kaufen und noch mal spielen
oder ich gehe mal kurz hier cancel und join wieder neu rein jetzt bin ich in q 2 von 2
ja danke battlefield sehr gut ja witcher 4 habe ich auch gerüchte gelesen das wäre
aber auch mal ehrlich gesagt das beste was sie machen könnten nach der verkackten cyberpunk
geschichte und es muss halt ein richtig gutes witcher 4 werden und dementsprechend dauert
es wahrscheinlich ewig ich glaube sogar dass die in witcher 4 schon dran sind wenn ihr
mich fragt ich glaube sogar dass die schon eine ganze weile an witcher 4 also ich meine
mit dran nicht dass da jetzt irgendwie 500 leute oder so dran entwickeln ja aber ich
meine ideen also story ideen überlegen vielleicht schon die ein oder anderen sachen ausprobieren
könnte ich wecken da sind die schon am start ja ansonsten interessiert mich da aber eigentlich
nicht so viel davon so jetzt müsste die runde mal zu ende gehen dass wir joinen können
habe ich nichts mehr großartig zu erzählen das kommt drauf an was du machen willst
der raspberry pi kann für dich sehr nützlich sein oder komplett useless je nachdem was
du machen willst oder was du vor hast oder was du damit umsetzen willst das ist genauso
wenn ich fragen fragen würde lohnt es sich einen tennis schläger zu holen oder ist der
komplett useless wenn du tennis spielst es ist wahrscheinlich sinnvoll sich einen tennis
schläger zu holen ja tv hock danke für den sub runde ist gleich rum pock ich glaube
zu monero mein ereignet sich der raspberry pie nicht sonderlich gut oder wir fallen
wirklich keine spiele ein jetzt noch die 2022 rauskommen soll auf die ich mich richtig
freue ich persönlich bin ja ein fan von so classic classic rpg's fand das neue pass
finder game mega nice oder so lasse aber richtig gut und dementsprechend freue ich mich natürlich
auch richtig auf baldus geht drei wobei baldus geht drei wahrscheinlich eher an ein divinity
original sind drei erinnern wird als an ein richtiges baldus geht drei aber das glaube
ich nicht dass es 2022 rauskommt aber ansonsten ja es kommt erstmal god of war für den pc
das werde ich auf jeden fall auch mal spielen ich habe mich bisher immer davor gedrückt
obwohl ich eine ps4 habe heute ratet mal jetzt und ich meine das jetzt wirklich so ernsthaft
ja also die wenigen stunden die rauskommen ratet mal wie viel stunden ich vielleicht
meine xbox one und ips 4 anhatte zusammen beide konsolen zusammen also die letzte konsole
generation 50 stunden ich würde ganz ehrlich ich würde sagen unter unter 20 stunden beide
zusammen xbox one habe ich glaube ich noch nicht mal ein spiel dafür außer das was
dabei war und das war fifa das habe ich nicht mal eingelegt und ps4 habe ich glaube ich
das last of us one remake das habe ich auch nicht ganz durchgespielt also ja und unter
20 stunden fifa stream erstmal erstmal karten kaufen erstmal 5000 euro gamble boah das muss
eine richtig krasse runde sein hier in der ich nicht drinne bin busch kaleidoskopier nicht
push russ russ oh nee ist es immer noch auf dem dach seriously ernsthaft die objectives
sind immer noch auf dem dach in rush dice ist jetzt durch als dann soll es ja gleich
losgehen zu nein habe ich nicht hat mich nicht so angesprochen ich mag so diese pirate settings
nicht ich weiß es gibt leute stehen total auf pirate sachen ich mag er pg mittelalter
setting weiß ich was bevorzugt ihr für irgendwelche roleplaying games mittelalter fantasy angehauchte
oder eher pirate fantasy angehauchte settings ah jetzt geht's los draw mittelalter pirate
oh das ist tatsächlich ziemlich ziemlich als alles dabei also ich persönlich mag mittelalter
was ich überhaupt nicht mag sind so deswegen ist elix auch nicht wirklich mein setting
ich mag eigentlich keine science fiction settings für so klassische roleplay dinger
ja so ist elix gespielt oder wie war das so ich habe da einen bogen drum gemacht ich
habe widersprüchliche dinger gelesen manche haben gesagt ja einstieg ganz gut rest crap
müll für piranha balls verhältnisse die haben aber auch schon ganz schön abgebaut
die letzten jahre über die fände warum ist wir denn jetzt die fänden ich dachte wir
sind attacker manns habe ich jetzt jede halbe stunde rum gesessen für die fände stellt
jebaited alter jebaited jebaited sag mal chris wde ich habe mal eine frage hast du mit uns
auf watsch gespielt dein name kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor also handjo mein die fände die
fenster oder ist der name einfach nur ähnlich du hast das gemmlich mal ok ok ich habe versucht
leute jetzt müssen wir uns beeilen und bunny hoppen arsch wir sind nicht um die ecke gekommen
weil die bestimmt sind die auf dem dach bling also in headshot sound finde ich haben die
tatsächlich satis satisfying hinbekommen ja ein setting satisfying headshot sound ok
da machst du nix oder shotgun mann blies shotgun alter mein team das macht ja mal richtig
bämbel bämbel guckt euch an das fetzt richtig so mag ich das so mag ich das so muss das
sein bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel
bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel bämbel
Da gehts rein, da gehts rein, wie man so schön sagt in CS, da geht was rein, da geht richtig
was rein bei ihm.
Es gibt Conquest für Bad Company 2 Maps, ja, das Problem ist nur, dass ich Bad Company
2, wenn man das mit Bad Company 2 Soldiers spielt, Krutze spielt, also Bad Company 2
ist richtig, aber richtig mies umgesetzt in dem Game.
Was geht ist die Maps mit Battlefield 2042 Soldaten und Specialist zu spielen, das geht,
das ist tatsächlich ganz gut.
Oh oh...
oh shit lmg legit am start kommt mal clone wars hier 50 mal maria falck am start seht ihr das
maria falck only was hältst du eigentlich davon dass da ist jetzt bis januar urlaub hat was die
haben ob es ja nur oder ist gut könnte es gut dass die auch urlaub haben jetzt bei da ist
dieser kack tank da da machst du nix oh nice nice nice mvp alter mvp
die fuß als krasser mvp mann der fj hier oh shit weg gebürstet 23 alle der geht hier richtig durch
hat er den wallhack angemacht das ist aber auch gegen gegen die gegner wie die krass die
pushen ist es auch schwierig ranzukommen nein nein nein nein nein ganz schlecht
alles klar nice gg da habe ich die die geschwindigkeit nicht so richtig eingeschränkt
die gegner wollen es wirklich wissen die drücken krass rein halbes esl esl feine ich in den die
ihr könnt mich nicht retten vergesst vergesst vergesst wir müssen den pens mann irgendwie
bashen dahinten sporn sporn sporn leute
tja ob wir die auf wir haben dies ab alter pock und der pens mann ist glaube ich auch weg
oder ist noch einer gewesen jetzt er dauern ok gut jetzt aber
so wie der mit der ak ab geht muss ich ja mal ausprobieren aber dazu muss man halt
sie zielen können nice nice nice nice easy easy easy ok die mal lege henne lege henne
moment die lege henne ist ja außen das wird nur in das wird nur hier drinnen angezeigt
ok ich bin krass verwirrt bei den gegnern die machen mich fertig die gegner ich weiß
überhaupt nicht wo ich hinrennen soll aber zum glück hat der fj das alles im griff
der macht die alle mit der ak platt also angeblich wurde das gefixt das gegner unsichtbar sind
einfach einfach nichts machen und gewinnen gut pass auf ich habe schon wieder tolle hipfire
kills oder sowas leute bald ist schon spät der ist richtig hart am rein ficken chat ja das
habt ihr gut erkannt und ich habe auf 5 headshot kills ich drücke jetzt nix leute team wollt
ihr lieber attacker spielen oder noch mal defense was ist euch lieber weil ansonsten
gehe ich jetzt raus ist egal weg ist schon da ist dann spielen wir manifest noch defense
und dann spielen wir wieder attacker leider gibt es ja kein switchen da sieht man mal
wie halbherzig das wieder alles implementiert ist hat der patch was gebracht ach ich muss
sagen stabil war das game eigentlich zum größten teil schon also gecrashed ist es selten bei
mir zwar ich hatte ab und zu mal crashes aber relativ selten also das geht performance
mäßig hat sich nichts geändert was wie zum teufel sind die da schon dran wie schnell
das muss das muss wingsuit stels gewesen sein
ich weiß nicht mal wo die rum stellsten die gehts nass
von kass alter mann wo sind die hier die gegner wollen wissen also die sind richtig bärm
hier am start guckt euch das mann die sind hardcore drauf
also die defense runde machen wir jetzt noch danach mit text text
die sind über mir oder stelsen ja ja ist gut
er lebt doch noch hier oder alles klar es war jetzt nicht so gut es wird hier durch durch
die gegner gehen ja mal mega ab alter lull wird der richtige esl hobby hier
richtige esl hobby guckt es euch an richtige esl hobby richtige esl hobby mann die gehen
ja rein wie sonst was ich muss hier hoch der zieht sich die stellt da oben drauf garantiert
die gegner man richtig esl hobby ja es ist aber heftige esl hobby am start gerade die
wollen es die wollen es richtig wissen orne fatal fatal nein die sponsor webster clones
am start ok jetzt können wir noch mal
schieb was jawoll der ist da oben irgendwo 100 pro oder ist
mann hier ist noch mehr der ist bestimmt da oben passt mal auf ist er nicht ich bin
hier vorbei gejammt ich schnupp
fack alter das ist ja mal eine pro gamer esl hobby of doom hier das sind es die battlefield
finals oder was ok jetzt haben sie es jetzt haben sie es
wie manchmal der der der falsche mich aufgeht ein richtiger einst schäm ich habe den typisch
gesehen was zum unter mir unter mir in der es geschuldet
das ist wirklich esl hobby leute das sind das sind irgendwelche files die wir gerade
spielen
das war jetzt blöd jetzt wissen dass hinter ihnen wenn alles klar game nice gg ok alles
klar
alter game mann
fack intensives gameplay und dann die musik die musik ist poggers die passt zu allem level
zu die waffen in bot games ja klar habe ich auch schon gemacht klar ok ich muss hier weg
ich muss hier weg leute legehände die legehände muss muss hier raus ich hätte jetzt wetten
können der typ steckt hier irgendwo drin gachi bass mann bewegt sich pepo fett webster pepo
fett alter was benutzt du als barrel keine ahnung default default streamst du öfters
ab und zu ja ist nicht so ich finde das game gar nicht so geil also es ist nicht so leicht
das jeden tag super krass rumsucht kann ja
ja die sitzen ja wirklich überall ich war eine ritze gefangen genau haben disabled alles
das ist wirklich esl finals hier jetzt haben sie geahmt ok da kommen immer ran da kommen
wir nicht mehr ran
was da hoch
fack meine güte alter boah das ist aber geschwitzt gerade
ich schrei geschwitzt aber vielleicht also letzte base ist glaube ich noch am besten
zu die fände ok die puschen schon wieder richtig heftig auf a und b die ja die hier
die fände ist ja nicht richtig du bist kaum re-spawned und schon wieder
sind ja wirklich überall dafür dass du bf rentner bist kannst du gut melden im esl feil
ich gebe mir auch möge gerade aber die gegner drücken schon wirklich heftig gerade rein
alter das ist nicht normal also normalerweise ist es eher so auf einer arschbacke gespiele
jetzt kickt jetzt kickt spmm leute ich sag es euch spmm kickt
ohoh ohoh fack wie er wusste dass ich da stehe mit seiner fucking auto shotgun er wusste
es einfach dass ich um die ecke stehe wahrscheinlich auch motion sensor ja ich weiß auch nicht
was abgeht er ist elfein das gehen ab und wie unser squad ist richtig gut trotzdem
wird hier durch gepusht wie sonst was ok vielleicht haben wir jetzt chance ein bisschen
die fans aufzubauen wo sind eigentlich wo sind eigentlich die die anderen hier hier
drin naja genau war gesagt soll mir den entgegen pushen oder nicht scheinlich sind gegen pushen
die sinnvollere variant da zeitlupen flieger hauen wir schon mal motion sensor rein ok die
werden wie viele kommen da warum sind die auch so auf zack warum sind die auch so auf
zack und checken immer alles richtig im five hat gegner ohoh alter wo sport man denn hier
bisher du bist ja nicht mal objektiv dran wenn die jetzt legen um es zu diffusen six
hat nicht sich der 3 hat spawns alter wo sind die alle ist das hier 16 16 oder 128 128
ok was sagt die map die map sagt wir sehen nichts ok von wo kommen die überhaupt welche
richtung ist das hier so da da die richtung ungefähr ich werfe ich werfe da einfach
mal motion sensor in die richtung hier so motion sensor go gibby motion sensor oder
die haben lege henne gemacht leute lege henne da kommen wir überhaupt nicht hin zum diffusen
jetzt heftig keine chance da kommen wir nicht mehr rechtzeitig hin no chance nope hat sich
aus die lege henne komm mal hier jump shorted um die ecke wirst du hier jump shorted um
die ecke da kommt der krasse razor man und lege henne auf der anderen seite na geil nein
game ok nehme ich auch nehme ich auch so nicht geplant aber ok was auf da kommen gegner rein
hier ich habe jetzt einfach die tür ab sobald ein gegner reinkommt bär mit kopf hier ist
der kopf ungefähr oder auch nicht ich gehe mal wieder hoch
die geilen stelzer überall
richtung shotgun player shotgun player in bond
hier hat weniger radiosongs als battlefield 2042 das schlecht weil radiosongs den monka
tos monka tos ist für streamer tos tos sagt falls man diesen absolut bescheuerten satz den
ich gerade rausgebracht habe irgendwie verstehen würde was ich meine aber ich glaube ihr versteht
was ich meine oder chat wir haben mittlerweile schon so heif heif meint wenn ich irgendwas
total verwirrendes bescheuertes sage dann versteht mich der chat oder ne nicht wie ihr versteht
mich nicht ja ich meine halt tos wegen streaming tos und so radiosongs sind radiosongs sind
halt immer tos
rauspushen
wir haben es easy wir haben die esl finals gewonnen wir sind battlefield europa champion
easy win 2 euro preisgeld mehr gibt es ja von dem prime sub nicht mehr müsst ihr alle
primes haben fürs primes fürs preisgeld primers any primers huge aber richtig coole runde
eigentlich richtig geschwitzt was schreibt der chat no one cares about leafgap das sind
halt die üblichen salty pepegas die es so gibt aber auf der anderen seite haben sie
den all chat entfernt was hat es uns jetzt rausgezogen oder wir wollten wir wollten
ja eh attacker spielen und nicht defender ja ok kann man den chat ausmachen ich weiß
es nicht ich finde all chat ist überhaupt kein problem also klar wird da geflammt aber
ich meine es ist battlefield es ist jetzt nicht so als wird er wirklich im sekundentakt
die mutter beleidigt sicherlich auch mal ja aber nicht so extrem ich weiß nicht ob
dies nie mal irgendwelche competitive games gespielt hat von cs bis lol bis overwatch
ranked was auch immer was da für einen toxic shit am start ist sind sind ordentlich leute
ich ziehe noch mal raus team team ich ziehe raus ich will attacker spielen kann bock auf
nochmal defender du du du du du du du du du du du was ist für ein sound leute ich bin
ja ein bisschen enttäuscht oder enttäuscht also nee muss ich anders sagen ich bin ja
insofern ein bisschen ich habe schlechte ich habe die schlechte vermutung dass halo
infinite dadurch dass die kampagne so sagt auch im multiplayer nicht so viele spieler
dazu bekommen wird ich würde das im multiplayer macht richtig spock aber viele leute kommen
halt durch die kampagne und die kampagne ist als story mäßig crap und auch open world
design technisch crap jetzt können wir attacken poggers poggers
das darf das halo streben die habe einmal halo gestreamt hat man schon gesehen dass
ich ein bisschen was dazu gelernt habe nicht so nicht gut in halo bin ich bin das platin
3 fast platin vier platt chat ist real game ja please
die shotgun oma die shotgun oma hat es nicht hingekriegt habt ihr es gesehen
die shotgun oma hat gemisst
wer sagt dass die infinite infinite kampagne die beste ist wer sagt denn so was
das können nur richtige pp gas sagen
halo und open world funktioniert nicht zusammen und die story ist ich kann wieder nicht springen
Leute ja mehr kopfschüsse please
darf ich wenigstens aufstehen ich habe springback
meinte ich habe sie gesehen
die shotgun oma man
zu viel zu viel so viele omas mit shotguns hier das ist doch nicht normal sind wir sind
wir in usa oder was
kann ich denn hier
mein game hat einfach auf die erde geguckt
das spiel ist so kaputt das game hat einfach so gemacht gerade das war ich nicht das hat
einfach auf die erde geguckt
warum du das spiel gekauft hast ja das war keine gute idee
hallo ich will springen
ach mist
ja warum das spiel gekauft hast ist wirklich eine gute frage keine gute idee gewesen definitiv
ich hätte ich hätte auch erst mal abgewartet aber ich hatte den kod
kodke hatte ich kodke
kamen hier durch rennen ich mein wenn es battlefield 3 wäre dann wäre das ziemlich clever man
könnte hier durch
ja game hallo please hallo sterben
leute weiß nicht ob die hitrex so komplett gefixt
ist oder war da was dazwischen da war da waren die kona flaggen dazwischen hier deswegen
hat das nicht funktioniert
aber wenn ihr das sagt dann muss es so sein
die viele shotgun oma
die viele shotgun omas es hier gibt
pass auf die nächste die nächste
hier keine shotgun oma aber aber auch shotgun
erst mal einfach hip feiern alles
weiter wie viele kommen da noch
wie viele kommen den achtung achtung big brain play big brain play leute
big brain biggest brain play seht ihr das
messer 5 hat der kopf platz gleich so big brain ist das schon
alter der kopf explodiert
der pc explodiert auch auf auf auf bewegt euch
hier darf man gar nicht raus
es ist auf dem dach es ist auf dem fucking dach man
es ist wirklich auf dem dach da ist common wie haben wir das eigentlich so schnell gelegt
reingeslidet noch gachi base
dachke achtung achtung dachke
brain break
das war ein gegner hinter mir
also ich hab nicht mitgekriegt
da ist der fatal best fatal macht es bämbel bämbel bämbel
komm mal hier wir haben es fast wir haben es fast fast alles fast alles clear fast alles
alles clear hier auf dem dach schnell auch rein spawn
fast alles clear clear
jawoll jawoll nice so nice so
das ist der heli
jetzt
easy nice
das hatte ich ja noch nie ich habe noch ich glaube diese objectives habe ich noch nie
gewonnen
lone wars
gg eats monarch s
52 assist der hat mit motion sensors um sich geschmissen
passenger assist ja der war wichtig
ich weiß nicht wie viele kills waren aber die war nicht wichtig der eine passenger assist
das war der was die runde gewonnen hat
taug der patch was
naja das spiel taugt immer noch nix
der patch macht es an manchen stellen etwas besser aber
nicht viel
ergeblich ist die hit right besser habe ich jetzt aber noch nicht so viel von gemerkt
die
fahrzeuge sind ein bisschen weniger brutal gegen infanterie vor allem der getrobte panzer
wohl gegen helis immer noch bämbel bämbel bämbel
reinhauen
es muss klatschen macht eigentlich mein aktuelles video wie läuft denn das so
zurück wer es noch nicht gesehen hat leute zurück zu bell viel drei
wird
ok doch eigentlich
es sich nachher
ja glaub schon aber ich glaube es gab auch konquest 1616 oder oder war das konquest
auch 12 vs 12 also
24 player tatsächlich auf der xbox glaube nur
ja leider leider hat es ja wenn es nicht so auf die reihe bekommen
leider hat es wenn es verkackt allerdings nicht technisch sondern eher so wie die sich
verkauft haben und organisatorisch und auch die sache mit kein offiziellen server und
so dass es so komische
so nur so komische server settings gab und die admins teilweise selbst gehackt
gehackt haben auf den server
oder der hat ins gesicht bekommen
eben warst du level 60 jetzt bist du wieder level 59 wirklich
in dem game wundert mich nix in dem game wundert mich nix
ob ich mit gerechnet dabei habe ich den eigentlich auf der map sehen müssen
ok mein team carried hoffentlich wieder
sieht aber fast so aus als carried das team das team carried immer ein richtig nice squad
was wir hier am start haben
richtig massive poggers squad
achtung wir machen jetzt wieder wir machen jetzt next level big brain play wenn man
hook wieder da ist
mensch
wollte richtig hier auf die andere seite sliden und hat er sich gedacht nop
jetzt wäre ich auch noch gerätzt man das ist ja man könnte ja fast meinen es gibt
hier so was wie team play in dem spiel
monac s so wo geht hier was
da sind sie
den eigentlich schreitzen koma k 30 k 30 extended merck wir können mal zur abwechslung wieder
mp9 spielen was haltet ihr denn davon
ich spiele mal wieder zur abwechslung mp9
mp9 extended merck jawoll passt
century gun
ja benny ich würde solltest du solltest auf jeden fall warten
guck mal hier mvp das mein mein team ist so krasse krasse mvp
die shotgun oma ist da
hallo meine maus please
da kommt noch einer rechts nein
fack jetzt sind wir alle dauernd
ich hab grad richtig in die fresse gekriegt ja
alter
mein gott wo kommen die alle her
fj macht das der muss karen der muss karen
ok jetzt gehen wir rein
achtung die kommt jetzt um die eck auf
ich kacke nur mann warum switch ich warum switch ich nicht einfach meine max richtig
dumm richtig dumm
ich denke da immer nicht dran
oh hinter mir
ist ja richtig high octane rush heute haben wir wieder muni jawoll
haben wir wieder muni auch hinter uns ist noch was ich glaube die sind auf dem dach
kann es sein
game hallo nicht stacken
hallo mein springen ist wieder kaputt mein springen ist wieder broken
gg nice game kann wieder nicht springen
doch das game wird langweilig das springen spiele ich das ja auch nur 1 1 2 mal wenn
es hoch kommt die woche
kann ich wieder springen jawoll springen geht wieder
so da hauen wir jetzt den motion sensor rüber und gucken wir was was da geht
oh oh oh oh da geht ordentlich was
was ja bekanntlichermaßen was ja bekanntlichermaßen alles fix
ist da war einer über mir gachi bass
das ist keine beta das ist early design phase hier was wir spielen
jawoll
kann ich da glaube nicht reißen ich probier es
oh man die sind aber auch so auf zack heute die gegner du kannst dir echt nichts erlauben
so nach dem motto ach komm ich versuche mal ob wir den typ des teammate retten können
doch nöb aber fj carried wieder so ist es gut nice
da macht es wieder solo ok da macht es solo solo mitten in der
base und die kriegen nicht da
das ist early access alpha ja das ist ungefähr auf dem stand wie pupke als es raus kam
ich meine die parallelen sind schon sind schon vorhanden oder pupke lief auch wie kurze
hier über range ist es nicht so geil
es wird niemals kommen ich vermute doch
allerdings dann in irgendeiner form nicht wie wir das erwarten
sondern als irgendwie mobile game ableger oder irgendwie so ein shit
ach das ist ja aus nicht vergesst das immer
keine chance also jetzt drücken die gegner aber mal richtig krass
ich glaube wir müssen abcranen ich glaube ich glaube wir müssen abcranen
oder downcranen wieder 23 noch
es macht aber einen riesen unterschied mit den motion sensors leute ne
findet ihr nicht auch die machen einen richtigen unterschied
jetzt wo nicht mehr jeder daher gelaufene kacke nur den motion sensor am start hat
mein gott game funktionier halt
lege henne
ok das könnten wir haben das könnten das könnten wir haben
nein da ist wieder einer dran mann scheiße jawoll jawoll jawoll jawoll
fatal fatal du machst das pock hast pock pock in der s jawoll wir haben es sehr
gut excellent excellent
so muss es sein
ich werde ich werde gestalzt ok jetzt jetzt definitiv nichts mehr aber
dann nehmen wir es noch was hier gehen wir nicht raus wir machen flank action
leute ist es schon spät es ist schon spät
ne noch zwei minuten dann ist schon spät noch ist nicht spät also fj du musst mir
manchmal die gameplays schicken hier der geht der geht ja so da geht ja so rein
bei ihm und ich denke schon immer so meine 20 30 kill gameplays in guten der
hat bei der mitte der da ist bei der mitte der runde schon irgendwie 44
wie dies wissen dass ich da oben einfach jetzt rauskommen
reds
eigentlich auch da kommt die oma die machen alle die die die challenge die
machen alle die die die defi defi challenge
die haben mich so haben hat ab überall
so wir schmeißen jetzt hier mal das ding drüber
es sich normal alle du machst deinen kopf raus und und dir schießt die
schießt direkt ein an ok kommen wir irgendwie weg ich probiere es mal
wir müssen weg so und jetzt stellst du mir da von der seite rein wenn sie
weg gebashed von der seite falls sie noch da sind da fallen die haut schon
rein fj macht das wir müssen ja erst mal durchkommen wir sind dann wir haben ja
die erste die erste base und immer richtig in der bau ist da können wir
hin das ist halt nicht so geil dafür und was trocken die denn eigentlich von
was trocken von ihrem heli hinter uns
jetzt hatte ich nicht mehr genug was haben die eigentlich für einen mega
respawn die gegner bis wir kommen ja keine zwei meter nach vorn das ist
wieder richtig bettel viel esl pro series hier
lasst mich rein lasst mich rein gatschi bus
zwischenzeitlich schon fünf mal hingelaufen er ist da alleine um die
drumherum 50 50 punkte und ich klicke hier schon die ganze zeit gleich der
datke gleich der datke
ja du musst v drücken game please
irgendwo
ok nice sehr gut sehr gut perfekter spawn spiel
perfekter sporn ich frage mich immer wie wir das verlieren können ich mein das
quad geht mega krass ab
wir haben nur noch zehn orschitt bloß noch zehn
wir müssen da jetzt ran leute das bleibt nichts anderes übrig
ok jetzt wer schneller basloyd
Okay, keine Chance, keine Chance, also mehr konnte ich jetzt wirklich, wie krass sind
die denn reingesporn? Die haben da bloß 16, die haben da bloß 16 Spieler. That's it again.
Ja stimmt, die haben auch wiederbelebt, ja die haben auch wiederbelebt, stimmt schon. Wisst
ihr warum? Weil es eine midic-defi-challenge gibt. Ein Spiel noch Leute, ein Spiel noch,
dann Betke. Ein Spiel dann Betke, weil schon spät, schon spät. Boomer müde, schon spät.
Im guten Squad rettet es das Game ein wenig, ja das stimmt schon. Aber du kannst alles,
also alles macht Koop ja mehr Spaß. Und vor allem wenn du Gegner bashst. Und es sind auch
gerade wirklich gute Gegner, muss man mal sagen. Ich glaube das liegt daran, weil die Rush-Playlist
nicht mehr so prominent platziert ist. Bis ja als Rush noch quasi auf der Startseite gestanden hat,
hat es jeder Hintz, wie sagt man Hintz und Kunst? Keine Ahnung. Ja und SBMM natürlich,
was sonst? Hallo warum habe ich auf einmal die, die Waffe? Hä? Ich hatte zum Schluss
eine andere Waffe, SBMM. Es gibt kein SBMM, das halte ich für ein Gerücht. Warum sollte man
alles schaffen dafür, Voraussetzungen, um SBMM zu machen. Ich meine jetzt ob es den Portal Rush,
welches gibt es, haben wir dahingestellt. Aber alle Voraussetzungen sind ja da. Du hast kein
richtiges Scoreboard, du hast Squads, die sich random zusammensetzt, du suchst nach jedem,
nach jedem Match neu. Warum baut man die kompletten Voraussetzungen für SBMM und hat
auch die übelsten Nuke Protections und sowas alles drinne und die größte Nuke Protection mit
SBMM baut man, alles klar, da ist, baut man nicht ein. Jetzt mal wirklich, glaubst du das denen nur
weil die das gesagt haben? Ich glaube denen nichts. Ich glaube denen einfach mal gar nichts,
was sie sagen. Die haben so viel gesagt, die haben auch Anfang des Jahres noch gesagt,
sie sind ahead of schedule. Also was die so sagen, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Und
wenn es das jetzt nicht gibt, wird das kommen. Es ergibt einfach aus ökonomischer Sicht mehr
Sinn und man hat alle Voraussetzungen dafür. Ich zeige euch jetzt mal Battlefield für 6 gleich. Ich
wollte euch Battlefield für 6 zeigen, aber ich kann euch keine Battlefield für 6 zeigen.
Unter mir war was, glaube ich. Okay, passt mal auf Battlefield für 6 Leute, guckt mal.
Das fehlt ja den Fallschaden ab, ganz logisch, oder? All-out Warfare, finde ich,
wird nicht unbedingt durch die Spieler schwierig, sondern weil es so unpredictable ist durch die
durch 128 Spieler. Aber ich würde mir in den Arsch beißen, wenn es nicht irgendeine Art von
SBMM gäbe. Ja klar, oder zumindest geplant ist das einzuführen. Irgendwie habe ich gedacht,
wir sind Defense. Ich weiß auch nicht warum. Irgendwie dachte ich, wir sind Defense. Wahrscheinlich,
weil wir hinten komisch rumgespawnt sind. Wo? Du ziehst dich ja freilieferlich an. Was hat
SBMM mit Bots zu tun? Bots würden ja gerade noch mehr für SBMM sprechen. Wenn nicht genug in dem
Skill-Rank da ist, wird halt mit Bots aufgefüllt. Gehen wir mal hier rein, gucken was da. So,
welches haben wir denn? Ach, wir haben noch gar nichts davon und wir haben nur noch 25 Tickets.
Alter, das ist ja noch eine kurze Runde, wenn wir das nicht hin kriegen. Alter, was ist mit euch los,
man? Was haben denn Bots? Ich kenne erstmal nicht, was Bots überhaupt mit SBMM zu tun haben. Und
wenn, würde es doch eher dafür sprechen, dass man sagt, es sind halt nicht genug Leute da. Man
füllt halt mit Bots auf. Also, hä? Nein, ne Güte, Alter. Kann ich das mal ein bisschen
weniger verziehen, please? Fuck. Doch, doch, ich hatte schon Bots. Jawohl, das haben wir. Okay,
jetzt B, jetzt B. Revive gibt es nicht. Ich glaube, das schaffen wir nicht. Okay, nice.
Schaffen wir rüber. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Fuck. Okay, das war so kurz, da konnten, nee, wobei,
ich mache jetzt Schluss. Wieso ich keinen Redout spiele? Weil ich Ironside-Enjoyer bin. Ich mag
Ironsides. Das reicht für heute. Boomer, müde. Boomer, Schluss. Morgen zur Arbeit. Nein,
ich muss nicht morgen zur Arbeit. Ich habe frei bis Januar. Excellent, excellent Leute.
Ja, Empire Kills. Aber nice Quad, Leute. Richtig poggers. Hat tatsächlich Bock gemacht,
auch wenn das Game immer noch ziemlich pepega ist. Richtig nice. Nicege. Was ist denn morgen?
Morgen ist Freitag, ne? Top, dann mache ich erst mal Vormittags Wanderstells, 2-3 Stunden.
Ja, Leute. Schon spät schlafen. Ich gehe jetzt ins Bett. Also, mehr Battlefield 3 Videos. Keine Ahnung,
wo ich... FG, richtig nice. Wenn ich das nächste Mal streamen kann, kannst du gerne wieder rein.
Du bist ja richtig krass abgegangen. Richtig nice. Richtig gutes Quad heute auch. Ja, Eax
macht es gut. Jett macht es gut. Bis morgen. CU.